Moin Leute, ich muss noch mein Brötchen fertig futtern. Und was habe ich die Woche verpasst? War irgendwas Spannendes?
Außer die SSH Sicherheitslücke.
Ne, ich glaube nicht. Kann mich nicht daran erinnern.
Wir haben auch unterschiedliche Arten und Weisen, schon Container Images gebaut.
Aber ich glaube mit Packer
noch nicht.
Und ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher, ob ich jemals Packer verwendet habe. Bilder habe ich schon verwendet, aber Packer? Keiner.
Ne, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, ich glaube noch nie.
Warum willst du das verwenden? Willst du
Quasi Container bauen ohne Docker in Docker oder?
Da weiß ich mal, Package Updates.
By the way.
Vor allem Images.
Ne, habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Gucken, ob es schon Package Updates wieder gibt.
Was? Was ist da los?
Wie?
Gibt keinen neuen Package Updates.
Bin geschockt. Arch, by the way, Rolling Release.
Wie kann das sein, dass es seit 13 Stunden keine Updates mehr gibt?
Das ist einfach nicht mal Bleeding Edge genug.
Da bin ich nicht mit einverstanden. Da gehe ich nicht d'accord mit.
Oder wie sagt man dann?
18 Stunden altes Betriebssystem verwenden.
Also das finde ich schon grenzwertig.
13 Stunden altes Betriebssystem.
Ich werde nervös, wenn mein Betriebssystem älter als eine Stunde ist seit dem letzten Update.
Also, du, ein Terraform Buch.
Echt? Gibt es da etwas Gescheites?
Ich habe das immer durch Try'n'Error und Ausprobieren gelernt,
Also die meisten dieser Tools ...
Hups.
Habe ich irgendwas runter geschmissen?
Ah, ich habe den Schalter
auf meinen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch runter geschmissen.
Ding ist halt
ich habe zwar einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch, aber
ich höhenverstellbar den Schreibtisch nicht.
Ich höhenverstellbar den Schreibtisch nicht.
höhenverstellbar denn so gut wie die damit so gut wie sie sehr sehr selten nur höhenverstellbar
einmal die woche geupdatet wie kann man so arbeiten ihr habt aber wahrscheinlich auch
nicht schlien ux bei dabei ach so regnen jetzt muss ich gerade sehen sie gesehen bei uns auf
github ist ja bei uns ja da wo deine bilder da wo deine bilder sind da hat einer ein issue
aufgemacht und ich finde das ist gar nicht so verkehrt er hat geschrieben warum gibt es auf
github so viele leute die white paper dann einen issue aufgemacht dass es nicht sein kann oder dass
es schlecht für den pepo ist wenn er sich nur abends die zähne putzt und nicht morgens vielleicht
könntest du den ja auch noch morgens die zähne putzen lassen anstatt also nicht anstatt sondern
zusätzlich zu abend
das kann theoretisch sogar das gleiche bild sein nur mit anderen hintergrund einfach den zahnbürsten
pepo doch morgens ja sehe ich auch vielleicht fällt ja noch irgendwie was ein dass man das
morgensbild bisschen anders machen kann aber eigentlich ist egal es kann auch einfach das
abendsbild sein nur mit anderen hintergrund weiß ich was morgens beim zähneputzen anders ist also
der unterschied bei mir ist morgens beim zähneputzen zum abends das meistens noch ein rasierer daneben
aber der pepo muss ich ja nicht rasieren der ist ja immer sehr sehr glatt morgens mittags abends ja
du hast nicht unrecht aber ja machen wahrscheinlich die wenigsten was ich was ich teilweise mache ist
was ich was ich teilweise mache ist ja das kann man tatsächlich tatsächlich machen was ich teilweise
mache ich habe so eine zahn zwischen raumbürste oder wie auch immer man das nennt so eine kleine
und das kann ich wirklich empfehlen
dass es sehr nahe ist zwischen raumbürsten sowas hier ja diese sorte habe ich muss mal gucken welche
größe die habe ich das stimmt überhaupt nicht die habe ich überhaupt nicht die doch doch die habe ich
aber nicht die in rot muss man sich die größe mal rausholen die sind das sind ganz ganz dünne zahnbürsten
und da kommt man zwischen die zwischen die zähne unten und gerade wenn man mittags irgendwie hähnchen oder sowas gefuttert hat der ist ja nicht so schön
oder irgendwas wo man gerne mal zeug in den
zähnen stecken bleibt ist das viel besser als irgendwie zahnseide oder sowas
zahnseide brauchst du an andren stellen aber da bekriegst
du den ganzen dreck mit raus den du den ganzen tag sonst irgendwie in den zähnen hängen hast also das mache ich mittags teilweise
ja aber ich putze ansonsten eigentlich auch nicht regelmäßig mittags nochmal
die zähne außer außer dass hier das benutze ich öfters mittags man das ist das ist wirklich also das kann ich generell für mich auch nirgendwann machen håndeschmack
das ist das ist wirklich das kann ich generell für mich hochkriegt ja aber nach dem antrieb das kann ich nur damit machen was ich über die zehne mache und das ist dann so dass ich dann kannst du alles mit dir machen
für morgens mittags abends empfehlen das ist super praktisch und wenn man probleme hat irgendwie ab
und zu mal mit bisschen wundem zahnfleisch und so was liegt es ja oftmals einfach weil er dreck
gerade sind inzwischen räume der dreck drin ist das hilft richtig was und es kostet so gut wie
nix also wenn ihr irgendwie zahnfleisch probleme habt oder generell so irgendwie das nicht probiert
das mal aus ihr müsst einfach nur die richtige größe raussuchen gibt die gibt es in ganz ganz
unterschiede die blauen sind glaube ich die kleinsten die sind nur okay sie nicht die
kleinsten übrigens sind doch nicht die die ich habe das sind nicht die ich habe ich habe irgendeine
die hatte ich mal ausprobiert hier aber die waren viel zu hart die waren viel zu hart ich habe ich
habe andere wir sind viel besser weil weicher aber finde ich zumindest kann ich die dinge echt
empfehlen
zeige euch dass mal welche das welche die richtige ist wenn man jetzt auf amazon
gescheit nach bürste einfach nur suchen könnte da aber das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren ach doch hier cps cps ja hier die da da unterschieden größen die habe ich und
die sind messe fork die sind weich und man kommt nicht mehr dazu wie zu jagen wenn man das mal so ist
überall rein und man hat quasi noch so 123 mal insgesamt 55 bürsten die man rein raus klipsen
kann also die dinger kann ich echt nur empfehlen das ist mega nice bringt richtig was so arch
bei the way wurde rebootet warum auch immer macht eigentlich keinen sinn aber hauptsache
wir haben rebootet man hat mittlerweile zumindest eher die chance mittags das auch zu machen weil
home office stellt jetzt immer vermehrt eine zahnseite ist für was anderes zahnseite brauchst
du eher an der anderen an den rändern nach oben hin und diese zwischenbürsten brauchst du unten
da wo das zahnfleisch ist deswegen kann ich auch sagen wenn man ab und zu mal probleme hat dass das
zahnfleisch ein bisschen wund ist oder sowas und generell irgendwie denkt aber so zu mit der zahn
weh das kann oftmals vom zahnfleisch kommen und diese diese interdental zwischenraum bürsten
richtig gut dafür
das dauert ein paar tage bis ich das alles wieder beruhigt hat wenn das erstmal entzündet ist ich
hatte richtig probleme ganz hinten links vor einer weile weil du da einfach nicht reingekommen bist
und seit ich dort regelmäßig mit diesen zwei zahn zwischenräumen bürsten dazwischen gehe ist das
alles weg und da blutet auch nichts mehr da fühlt sich nichts mehr wund an das ist richtig nice diese
dinge kann man echt nur empfehlen ihr könnt die euch natürlich über mein amazon raffling kaufen
ich kann es echt empfehlen geht ja auch alle sechs monate zum zahnarzt das reicht ich hatte in den letzten jahren
nie großartig was ich hatte nur öfters mal wieder an den stellen problemen wo schon vorher was war
aber was neues hatte ich eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht kann mich jetzt eigentlich nichts erinnern
wo ich mal was neues hatte ich hab jetzt seit zwei jahren tatsächlich den ersten so
Halb nicht mehr echten Zahn.
Die untere Hälfte ist noch echt.
Die obere Hälfte ist nicht mehr echt.
Aber bei dem hatte ich schon
Jahrzehnte Probleme.
Und da war mittlerweile
einfach so wenig von dem Zahnebrechen.
Das Zahnarzt hat gesagt,
da können wir bald nichts mehr fixen.
Und bevor der anfängt durchzubrechen,
sollte man einfach oben drüber was drauf machen.
Das war teuer.
Ich habe mal die Rechnung gesehen.
Das hat irgendwie 1200 Euro
oder sowas gekostet.
Und einen Zahn zu fixen.
Geil, oder?
So, was mache ich eigentlich in meiner Artstealungs-VM?
Da müssen wir uns überhaupt nichts machen.
By the way, was haben wir hier eigentlich?
Stream-Themen.
Oh ja, da müsste was stimmen.
Stimmt, das habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Die ESP32-Sache wollte ich ja noch fertig machen.
Oh, was ist fertig? Fertig wird es ja nie.
Wie ist das in UK so?
Gibt es da auch so einen großen Unterschied
zwischen gesetzlich versichert
beziehungsweise selbst bezahlen
und privat versichert sein?
Also hier ist das ja mittlerweile
bei allen Ärzten enorm der Unterschied.
Wenn du gesetzlich versichert bist,
brauchst du beim Hautarzt ein halbes Jahr,
bis du drankommst.
Und wenn du selbst bezahlst
und privat versichert bist,
fragen sie dich so,
ja, reicht es Ihnen morgen Mittag noch?
Das Gesundheitssystem ist am Limit.
Also im Prinzip so wie bei uns auch.
Das ist halt echt ein bisschen für den Arsch.
Das ist aber, glaube ich,
mal gucken, was ich in ein paar Jahren sage.
Aber das mit dem
Privatversichern ist echt
die beste Entscheidung jetzt gewesen.
Also jetzt bietet es sich noch an
in meinem Alter,
weil ich habe ja auch noch nichts.
Und was richtig gut ist,
ich bin so fit und gesund
wie eigentlich noch nie vorher.
Also wenn ich jetzt wechsle,
wann dann?
Moin.
Nee, ich war noch nicht.
Dafür war ich gestern mehr,
als ich müsste.
Gestern
sah mein Plan eigentlich nur vor,
aber es wurde nicht voll,
aber es war,
quasi ich weiß gar nicht,
ich habe mir schon gewünscht,
dass meine Familie
auch noch ein bisschen
empathisch bleibt.
Jetzt kann ich ja ganz so
bei den Kindern
sagen,
ich weiß nicht,
wie es so läuft,
aber es ist ja einfach so,
dass ich mir jetzt
die Zeit ververkostet habe.
Das istayı,
das ist nicht so,
also,
damit ich mich jetzt
unter den Rasen
nicht vermute.
Aber die Leute,
die werden es nicht mehr so,
dass sie sich nicht mehr so viel
Kommen,
und dann ist man dabei,
und man muss ja nichts machen,
läuft das war gestern angesagt aber ich bin gestern tatsächlich dann ohne plan
ja ich habe so einen auto generator so einen trainingsplan generator aber ich
habe mir gedacht gestern eigentlich fühlst du dich ganz fit und dann bin ich
die gleiche strecke gerannt also irgendwie so siebeneinhalb oder so
kilometer gucken wie viel es genau waren dafür eine ganze ecke schneller als das
vorgesehen hat es hat natürlich auch nicht ganz 49 minuten gedauert aber es
war auch gut weil es angefangen hat zu regnen
das heißt gestern war schon eine ganze ecke anstrengender als geplant das
heißt ich mache jetzt erst mal nichts oder heute mittag mal gucken und mal
schauen vielleicht heute mittag vielleicht mal kurz gucken ob meine app
gesynct hat ja die garmin das die garmin leute sind auch so ein paar pp'ers
die verschieben laufen in der app irgendwelche sachen da findest du sie
nicht mehr hier 41 minuten waren es gestern anstatt 49 dafür deutlich
schneller
also anstatt 650 6 minuten 50 kilometer 55 der kilometer war eine ganze ecke
schneller dementsprechend natürlich auch kürzer naja die können sich in der
playlist mal wieder nicht entscheiden wie laut wie laut die einzelnen songs
sein soll das ist immer etwas problematisch gut ich meine
das ist meine grafik auf dieser app und auf so einer app kann man ja auch
einfach nur ein paar tipps auswählen man kann was anderes als das als das garmin
ökosystem nehmen mehr die ganzen kohlen fitness influenza haben ja alle ein
strava profil aber ich finde garmin connect echt nicht schlecht was da so
viele insights und ich finde die app es ich finde die app an sich nicht schlecht
das einzige was mich bei garmin connect nervt ist dass sie gefühlt einmal alle
weiß wo sie sind es ist auch so ein trend in viele software hersteller verfolgen kann man
den schritt irgendwo anders platzieren apple watch finde ich dafür aber nicht sinnvoll die
apple watch hat viel zu geringe laufzeit ich glaube apple watch ist was für leute die eine
smartwatch wollen mit smarten funktionen die sie halt den tag über benutzen und dann wieder
aufladen aber rein für sport tracking und so ist die apple watch nicht dass aus meiner sicht nicht
unbedingt das beste apple watch ist für leute die ihre musik steuern wollen jetzt nachrichten
lesen wollen die da drauf irgendwelche sachen notifications habe irgendwas ja plus nebenbei
vielleicht bisschen noch die die herzfrequenz aufzeichnen aber so rein als sport und glaube
ich ist die apple watch nichts nichts nicht so dass nonplusultra da finde ich die garmin dinger
besser die kannst du auch eine woche benutzen ohne dass da aufladen muss jetzt habe ich die
woche irgendwas sportlich
wie gesagt die ssh sicherheitslücke war ich suche ja immer noch eine schöne it news wochen
zusammenfassung die es irgendwie nicht nicht gibt also auch nicht warum das finde ich keine ich suche
da seit heise hatte früher mal eine aber die gibt es jetzt nicht mehr ich finde keine gescheite it
news wochen zusammenfassung die ungefähr das widerspiegelt was ich was mich interessiert 10
milliarden passwörter gelesen
dieser ausgleich ist so meiner sache vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr ausgewogen
wer hat denn dieses mal wieder was geleakt max liegt in der suppe hier
k märker man ei bild okay 99 milliarden passwörter sind das auch die der nutzer obamacare hat bei rock
rock you 2014 was für ein ding ich weiß überhaupt nicht was das was ist aber share hoster okay nicht
hinter dem dach jetzt ist er so wie es schon bisher war das ist jetzt das erste mal durch die
instanz идr Spiele in einem jahr von dem jahr 24 plan ist es durch die sich die französchischen
种en von immobilien etwas passiert und diese fälle der sich die wirken und diese werden hier
hauptregale die spezialisierte zähler auf die indetikaten der doings konzeptoren so wie er
hier in der sache und den handelsgegenstand so der mini handel mit einer kleinen kanal
ok nicht das erste und nicht das letzte liegt ja nee ja aber welche welche seite hat er wo
hat er denn die passwörter her das erkennt man da jetzt nicht so genau aber das sieht man gar
nicht woran das ja hier das ist so ein best of ding aus allen möglichen leaks okay dann lasst
uns mal kurz schauen bei twillow gab es auch ein league von 33 millionen telefonen mittlerweile
ganz im ernst die leute sind so abgestumpft durch die ganze leaks das ist eigentlich kein
mehr richtig interessiert normalerweise sollte man die häufigkeit dieser dinge mal zum anlass
nehmen sich zu überlegen muss man wirklich also erstens zwei sachen sollte man sich dort
als dem erstens möchte wirklich jeder dienst zwangsweise ein account haben der dann zwangsweise
auch zig daten haben muss damit man ihn benutzen kann die ja eigentlich gar nicht braucht das erste
also bei ganz vielen services die brauchen weder meine telefonnummer noch noch bräuchten sie
eigentlich meine e mail adresse noch bräuchten sie auf jeden fall irgendwie persönliche anschriften
und namen und solche geschichten das erste und das zweite ist eigentlich sollten dass die leute
mal diese häufigkeit zum anlass nehmen sich zu überlegen sollte man das ja ja das ist der beste
beste beispiel für die geforce experience den account braucht warum brauche ich einen account
um in meine grafiker über die grafik settings zu kommen ja ja und die leute
könnten sich auch mal überlegen ob man wirklich jeden scheiß irgendwo im
internet preis geben sollte dabei ist es ja relativ einfach war die
sache zumindest mal so grundsätzlich zu umgehen indem man erstens nur das raus
gibt das wirklich notwendig ist und dort wo die was wo die mehr haben wollen
als man raus geben möchte einfach fakes ab und wenn man den service trotzdem
benutzen will einfach fake kram einzutragen
es ist ja nicht verboten fake namen fake adressen fake telefonnummer oder sonst
was einzutragen natürlich wird das manchmal ein bisschen
schwierig wenn das verifiziert wird aber auch da gibt es möglichkeiten
die einfachste variante für e mail adressen ist tatsächlich also wenn man
so weit wie möglich unter dem radar fliegen möchte ja es gibt natürlich
anbieter die generell nicht anbieten
generieren einem das und gibt so was wie ten minute mail und alles mögliche aber
das wird ja oftmals mittlerweile erkannt am einfachsten ist tatsächlich wenn man
entweder zu ich habe vergessen gibt es gibt da so ein paar anbieter fällt mir
gerade keine ein weil ich nicht benutze da kannst du dir so alles alles
generaten lassen mit quasi custom endung oder das einfachste ist so wie ich das
gemacht habe wenn man sich einfach eine domain kauft oder fünf domains kauft oder
was auch immer ganz normale de domains oder dotnet.com
punkt info oder was auch immer und dort dann email adressen anlegt für die service
die man dann nach der anmeldung und das ist wahrscheinlich auch ganz praktisch nach der
anmeldung einfach nicht weiterleitet und dann hat man sich einmal gemeldet und gut ist so was
trendet denn heute auf schütte vielleicht vielleicht nicht unbedingt nur heute sondern
eine ganze woche ein open source pump tool alternativ zu cyberược okay das ist nice
CyberArk ist nämlich echt abfackextrem, aber das ist nicht einfach, dass man CyberArk bei vielen Läden durch ein anderes Tool ersetzen könnte.
Da hat sich ja irgendwie die halbe Firma drauf eingeschossen, dass man das verwenden muss.
Zumal das auch irgendein China-Chinesen-Tool ist, ich weiß nicht, wie oder keine Ahnung, was ist das für eine Sprache?
Deep L, guck mal, der präziseste Übersetzer der Welt, jawohl.
Chinesisch, ich glaube nicht, dass meine Firma dort, wo ich arbeite, fein damit wäre, CyberArk durch ein China-Chinesen-Tool zu ersetzen.
Obwohl es Open Source ist, aber da sind wir in der Versicherung zu Boomer-mäßig unterwegs.
Was trendet denn die Woche?
Hex-Editor, es trendet ernsthaft ein Hex-Editor, das ist ja auch mal was hier.
Hacker, Hacker, Mensch.
Alles klar, das finde ich ja tatsächlich interessant, dass man einen Hex-Editor trendet.
Der ist sicherlich deutlich advancer als Sachen aus den 90ern und 2000ern.
Basiert auf, ich würde sagen C++ wahrscheinlich.
Ja, so Dinger sind gerne C++.
Und auch hier unten.
Und auch hier immer.
Im Hex.
So neu kann der nicht sein, wenn der so viele Sterne hat.
Das finde ich cool, dass man einen Hex-Editor trendet.
Wenigstens mal was Gescheites, was trendet.
Nutzt du Hardware-Schlüssel für 2FA?
Ne.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen, tatsächlich meine Disk-Encryption noch zusätzlich mit einem zweiten Faktor zu encrypten.
Die neuesten Yubi-Keys sind ja nicht mehr Open Source, deswegen ist die Frage, ob es ein Yubi-Key wird.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Da bin ich gerade am schauen.
Und.
Das machen wir vielleicht auch demnächst im Stream.
Mit so einem Hardware-Fido-Token.
Aktuell habe ich einfach 2FA mit Handy-App und gut ist.
Und ich mache es auch echt über das Handy.
Ich habe das nicht über den Passwort-Save.
Auch wenn das einfacher wäre, das über den Passwort-Save zu machen.
Aber dann stellst du natürlich ein bisschen in Frage den Sinn.
Und.
Das zweite Faktor ist, wenn du im Passwort-Save, wo du dein normales Passwort drinne hast, auch quasi den OTP-Generator für den zweiten Faktor drinne hast.
Ne, ich habe Gmail nicht offen.
Ich kann mich auch gerade nicht einloggen, weil ich sehe auf dem zweiten Rechner hat es irgendwie Firefox updated und whatever, ich bin nicht mehr eingeloggt.
Das heißt, ich muss warten, bis ich umgeloggt bin nachher.
Aber ich schreibe es mir mal auf.
Dann.
Fixen wir das.
Du kannst auch theoretisch den Link zum.
Zum Bild einfach hier rein posten, dann können wir.
Wollen wir das jetzt machen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Deswegen bin ich da selbst noch am gucken.
Was ist das?
Ah.
Ah, da fehlt die Hälfte, weil die, weil die ihre URL so komisch formatieren.
Was hinter der Konto-Datenabfrage in der Bahn steckt.
Okay.
Okay, das ist schon aus Mai, aber schon einen Monat her.
Diese Anfrage überrascht derzeit, wer bei der Deutschen Bahn online eine Fahrkarte kaufen möchte, muss jetzt während der Buchung sein Bankkonto durch einen externen Dienstleister verifizieren lassen.
Dafür müssen sich die Kunden im Onlinebanking-System ihrer Bank anmelden, einschließlich PIN-Vielfältigen.
Ja, da wäre ich auch verunsichert, da wäre ich auch verunsichert.
Ich meine, du kannst doch nicht den Leuten auf der einen Seite sagen, ihr seid vorsichtig.
Wenn irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Abfragen.
Wenn irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Abfragen kommen und passt auf, dass ihr nicht gefischt werdet und so.
Wie versorgt.
Ja.
Und das sagt ja auch jeder so nach dem Otto.
Ey, gib dein Passwort niemals auf anderen Seiten ein.
Ja.
Tink und Wermi hat noch nie jemand gehört.
Da würde ich auch bei irgendwelchen random Sachen nicht meine Daten eingeben.
Die DB erhalt nur Infos über das erfolgreiche Login.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute trauen der DB mehr als Tink und Wermi, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ja.
Also, Otto Ident mit einem Maus.
Alter, ja, lasst mich halt einfach bezahlen.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich weiß noch, als ich vor allem, das ist ja schon eine Weile her, ja, wo ich letztes Mal auf der Gamescom war, habe ich mir auch gedacht, ich kaufe mir einfach über die Kölner Verkehrsverbund App eine Wochenkarte.
Vergiss es.
Da musstest du dich, glaube ich, noch per Post Ident freischalten lassen damals, dass es theoretisch ging.
Ich saß im Zug und dachte mir so, ey, lädst du dir mal die Kölner Verkehrsverbund App runterkommen?
Vergiss es.
Die machen es so unglaublich ätzend komplex.
Kompliziert.
Könnte ich einfach fucking Paypal akzeptieren?
Einfach Paypal?
Irgendwas, was die gesamte Welt hat?
Ich will nicht sagen, dass es das einzig Wahre ist, aber es funktioniert halt.
Wermi und Tink sind etablierte Firmen, das mag sein.
Ich habe noch nichts davon gehört und keine Sau hat jemals was davon gehört.
Jemand von euch jemals schon mal was von Wermi, also davor, ja, von Wermi und Tink gehört?
Kackla.
Ja, wenn Paypal geht, ist ja gut.
Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht, zumal die ja die Kontoverbindung dann schon kennen und wissen, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Also, ja, naja.
Aha.
Das ist nice.
Leute, neues Paypal-Bild.
Let's go.
Der muss sich morgens rasieren, ja.
Nice.
Haben wir die Bilder hier?
Ja, habe ich den Graben hier.
Repos.
White, pepo, happy, desktop, background, git, pull, origin, master.
Was?
Mein git benutzt 100 pro den falschen Key.
100 pro den falschen Key.
Weil eigentlich ging das.
Ich meine, ich konnte es ja hier schon mal klonen, ja.
Ja, dann scheitert es jetzt daran, dass ich mich nicht richtig einloggen kann.
Geil.
Aber ich mache schon mal den...
Ich lade schon mal das Bild runter.
Download, XP.
Oh, was ist das Neue?
Sunrise.
Das da.
Images.
Ja, da ist es.
Aber warum kann ich mich denn...
Kann ich noch pushen?
Ne, wenn ich nicht pullen kann, kann ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht pushen.
Ich vermute mal mein...
Ich habe doch gestern irgendwelche Keys generated, oder?
Welchen Key benutzt mein GitHub?
Ähm.
Man kann...
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Git specify SSH-Key.
Der nimmt bestimmt den falschen SSH-Key.
Wir können SSH-Config.
Ja.
Das könnte man machen, aber das...
Ich glaube, das...
Ich glaube, das fehlt mir einfach.
Konfig.
Die habe ich hier nicht.
Aber ich muss die hier schon mal gehabt haben, dass ich da gepullt habe.
Egal, ich mache das.
Ich pushe das später.
Aber wir machen jetzt hier schon mal den Eintrag.
Dafür.
So, und dann brauchen wir in der Readme.
Sunrise.
Wie heißt das Ding?
So.
Jetzt haben wir das Ding auch in der Readme drin.
Git-Status.
Git-Add.
Vomit.
Rush.
So.
Git-Push.
Mal gucken, ob ich pushen darf.
Ich bezweifle es ja.
Ne.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum meine SSH-Keys da irgendwie nicht funsten.
Ich wette...
Ich wette mit euch.
Das liegt daran, weil ich zu viele SSH-Keys mittlerweile generated habe.
Was ist denn der älteste SSH-Key?
Der hier.
Vermutlich ist das hier der richtige für GitHub.
SSH.Config.
Wie gibt man das an für...
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt...
Git.
Ey, ja, ja, ist klar.
Git.Git.
Was war das?
Was war meine Repo-Dings hier?
Die URL.
Git.GitHub.
Git.GitHub.com.
Können wir machen.
GitHub.com.
So.
Und da...
Ja, das brauchen wir, glaube ich, nicht.
Und da brauchen wir mal Identity-File.
ID.DSA.
Das da.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass das funktioniert.
Dass das der Key ist, den ich auch auf GitHub am Start habe.
Muss man nicht einfach sagen, so.
Da muss man nach Sternchenpunkt...
Ich versuche...
Ich versuche, den Key zu finden, den ich auf GitHub hinterlegt habe,
weil ich mich gerade nicht einloggen kann von hier.
Fuck.
Nee.
Muss man da...
Muss man dort irgendwie irgendwelche Wildcard-Geschichten machen?
Okay.
Ich muss es nachher pushen.
Keine Ahnung.
SSL-Config.GitHub.
Key.
Muss man da irgendwie Wildcard machen oder so?
Nee.
Ach, User.Git.
Ja, genau.
Genau.
Ja, ja.
Nee.
Okay, das ist nicht der richtige Key.
Was könnte...
Ja, so haben wir es.
Okay.
Was könnte denn sonst noch der richtige Key sein?
Also...
Das hier ist auf jeden Fall...
Ah, hier.
Nee, den hatten wir ja schon.
Also, der älteste ist tatsächlich hier der da.
Und ich hätte eigentlich gedacht...
Ich meine, wir können auch den RSA probieren.
RSA-Setge ist es auf gar keinen Fall.
Und Google ist es auch nicht.
Und DSA wird es auch nicht sein.
Also, gucken wir mal.
Also, wir haben noch...
Probieren wir mal aus, ja.
RSA.
Ja.
RSA wird es auch...
Der wird es nicht sein.
Ah!
Easy.
Wenn man halt 30 Milliarden SSH-Keys rumliegen hat bei sich.
Äh.
Ähm.
Ey, das ist...
Warte mal, das ist falsch, oder?
Ey, Rankman, guck mal, das ist verkehrt.
Das ist ein...
Das ist ein Sunset-Bild.
Wir brauchen eigentlich ein Sunrise-Bild.
Da ist der Hintergrund ist falsch.
Ähm.
Ist nicht das hier...
Ist nicht das hier Sunrise?
Ist nicht das hier Sun...
Ach, das ist Morning.
Dann mach das mal lieber mit Morning, hä?
Ja, das ist ja tatsächlich schwierig zu unterkennen.
Das ist...
Das ist Sunrise.
Okay.
Dann habe ich sogar falsch verstanden.
Weil Sunset und Sunrise...
Das ist ja nicht...
ziemlich ähnlich aus probier mal probiert es noch mal mit mit morning dabei und theoretisch
kann er auch durch durchaus noch bei sunset mit der probiert das aber mit morning dabei dann
hängen wir das um gleich also quasi nicht mit nicht mit sunrise sondern mit sondern mit dem
hier so oder ich muss mal so was von trinken aufs klo ihr dürft euch jetzt eine runde als
die quarry um im fullscreen angucken und ich muss mal zwei minuten kurz auf klo und dann
gucken wir uns bei youtube videos ab bis gleich jetzt bin ich wieder am start auf geht's hier
sind beide morning und sunset variant mit dabei exzellent morning also okay naja spock
very very pock
das heißt ich brauche im endeffekt noch toothbrush ich brauche noch den da na gut dann kopieren wir
das mal schnell überschreiben wir den alten oder ja die gibt es nur einmal den morning son morning
geht status dann sind wir mal so frei und machen einfach das letzte comment wieder rückgängig
brauche ich nicht jetzt
jetzt get reset jetzt status dann löschen wir den hier nämlich wieder den sunrise und gehen in
die read me rein und nehmen den da morning morning morning ist hier okay geht status
jetzt is com mit push force bam und jetzt haben Bob und Floss, Star tenants, take pause buy next,
und jetzt gammer den braun und bewegen die jako trifft wirklich ein bild von dem tested
vor zwei menschen am start aufs klo und kommen haupt und ab jetzt eine hügel auf die nackte
Den Pepo am Start, der sich
die...
Ah, PNG, PNG.
Sehr schlau, Max. Five-Hat-Time.
Wir hängen das einfach an und
pushen nochmal Force.
Ich bin der Einzige,
der in dem Repo was macht. Das ist erlaubt.
So, und jetzt sollten wir eigentlich
das passende
Bild drin haben.
Ja, nice.
Ja.
Exzellent, exzellent, exzellent.
Sehr nice, dankeschön.
Dann könnte ich jetzt
theoretisch das GitHub-Issue
zumachen, aber
ich bin nicht eingeloggt. Also, das
muss ich nachher machen. Ja, danke.
Sehr, sehr nice.
So.
Was können wir uns denn auf YouTube jetzt mal
zu Gemüte führen hier?
Hardware-Tour, ne.
Ein neues Fire-Chip-Video.
100 plus Linux-Things
you need to know.
Okay, das ist Fire-Chip, das geht schnell und das
Hälfte sind... Ich wette mit euch, die Hälfte
der Sachen sind irgendwelche Meme-Dinger.
Arch, by the way.
Wollen wir wetten, Arch, by the way, ist dabei?
Es ist... Okay, ich
predikte zwei Sachen, die dabei sind.
Arch, by the way, und
fuck you, Nvidia.
Können wir vorstellen, die zwei Sachen sind dabei.
Nee, wir spoilern nicht.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt aber an.
6% of the humans watching this video
are not using Linux.
And that's just like really sad, because it's a
superior, free, open-source operating system.
But only has a poor perception.
Übrigens, immer wenn ich das hier sehe,
immer wenn ich hier so eine Install-CD sehe,
muss ich dran denken, ich hab mir damals
tatsächlich Suse,
ähm, Suse Linux
4 oder sowas,
so eine blaue, das waren so, ja,
aber nicht die roten, die blauen.
Nee, nee, nee,
nicht 6, 4, nicht 6, 4, 4.
Und das waren so,
irgendwie so in der Richtung, das waren so
blaue
CDs,
ja,
und die gab es auch irgendwie als
Professional Edition
und die waren dann rot.
Und das war tatsächlich
mein erster Kontakt mit Suse
und auch
mehr oder weniger mein letzter Kontakt mit Suse,
weil seitdem mag ich Suse Linux nicht.
Das war eines der ersten Linux-Systeme, mit denen ich in Berührung
gekommen bin.
Ich mein, wann gab's, wann,
lass mal kurz gucken hier, History,
Release History, wann war Suse 4
am Start? Das müsste,
2000 oder so rum gewesen sein.
Nee, das ist zu früh.
Dann hab ich nicht 4, dann,
da muss was anderes gewesen sein, das ist definitiv zu früh.
Das ist definitiv zu früh.
Dann war's 6.
Dann war's wahrscheinlich 6
oder sowas hier, so in dem,
oder 7, irgendwie so
in dem Dreh müsste es dann gewesen sein, nicht 4.
Das, dann stimmt das nicht, was ich erzählt hab.
Ja, und
da hatte ich dann keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, stimmt, damals konnte man sich
kostenlos Ubuntu-CDs bestellen.
Richtig, ja. Eigentlich sehr nice.
Gibt's nicht mehr, gell?
Geh ich mal von aus. Denk mal, das haben die wieder eingestellt.
Okay,
dann schauen wir uns mal an, was uns Fireship zu sagen
hat, zum Thema
100 Sachen Linux-Dinger, die wir wissen müssen.
Und wie gesagt, ich
predikte, fuck you, Nvidia ist dabei und Arch, by the way.
Das andere fällt mir jetzt grad
nicht ein.
Statistically, 96% of the humans watching
this video are not using Linux.
Ja, weil's Kacknoobs sind.
Und weil nächstes Jahr
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops ist.
Am nächsten Jahr geht's durch die Decke, Leute.
Und natürlich nur mit
Wayland und Hyperland zusammen.
Wie wir gestern gesehen haben,
funktioniert das, gerade in VMs, funktioniert das
erstklassig.
Auf dem Desktop, wohlgemerkt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es
eine ordentliche Statistik gibt für
Betriebssysteme, Server-Betriebssysteme,
weil's immer ein bisschen schwierig raus
zu bekommen, auf welchem OS jetzt eigentlich
die Sache läuft, wenn man irgendwas
ausgeliefert bekommt.
Aber man kann so halbwegs
gut predikten. Also ich würd mal sagen,
Internet, also generell
nicht nur irgendwie
Webserver oder Internetseiten,
ich würd mal sagen,
Serververbreitung bei
so Public-Internet-Infrastruktur,
wo wir halt ein bisschen
was mit zu tun haben von NTP-Servern
bis DNS-Server, bis Webserver,
dort, wo die ganzen
Web-Anwendungen auch drauf laufen
und Datenbanken im Backend,
da würd ich mal sagen, sind wir bei 95%
Linux. Würd ich jetzt einfach mal
so tippen drauf.
Und bei so
rein internen Sachen ist sicherlich
Windows der Anteil noch ein bisschen höher.
Für irgendwelche internen
Tools oder irgendwelche Sachen, wo der Hersteller
sagt, oh, wir können das nur unter Windows,
da würd ich sagen, sind's vielleicht 80% Linux.
Aber bei so Public-Internet-Infrastruktur
würd ich sagen, 95% Linux.
Vielleicht ein bisschen hochgegriffen,
aber ich glaube
gar nicht mal so sehr. Weiß nicht, ob's dazu
Statistiken gibt.
Oh.
Nee, ja, nee, Bots.
Wollt ihr damit sagen,
dass 96,3% der Server...
Nee, glaub nicht.
Erlaubt mir, für einen Moment zu interagieren.
Es ist nicht Linux.
Es ist GNU-Linux, beziehungsweise
GNU plus Linux.
... into a Linux terminal
and fix it, you are screwed. In today's
video, you'll learn everything you need to know about
Linux by looking at 101
essential concepts over the next 10 minutes.
If you survive until...
Arch. Aber warum nicht Arch, by the way?
If you survive until the end,
you should magically grow a neckbeard
and be able to technobabble like an Arch-User.
Before one can understand Linux, though,
one must recognize what came before it,
Unix, an operating system
developed at AT&T Bell Labs in the 70s.
Its development led to a
standardization called POSIX,
or Portable Operating System Interface,
Ich hatte legit keinen Plan,
wofür POSIX steht. Wusstet ihr das?
... ensure that different
systems would be compatible with each other.
Its influence remains strong today,
with macOS, Android, FreeBSD
and most Linux distros being
POSIX compliant. In 1987
an OS called Minix for academic use
was developed, but redistribution of
its code was restricted. This inspired a
Finnish computer science student named Linus Torvalds
to develop Linux in 1991.
Importantly, it's free...
Man muss ja auch dazu sagen, wenn ich diese Story
noch richtig im Kopf habe,
dass es gar nicht seine Idee war, das Ding
Linux zu nennen.
Ich krieg die Story nicht mal richtig
zusammen, aber er hat ja wohl
die erste Linux-Version irgendwo hochgeladen,
ich glaube auf seinen FTP-Server
in der Uni.
Und da hieß das noch irgendwie anders.
Und der Admin von
diesem FTP-Server hat das
umbenannt in Linux.
Und seitdem hat's den Namen.
Er wollte es Freaks
nennen oder so. Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Genau, und
der Admin hat das umbenannt.
Hat er damals nicht als Zoo-Werte?
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist Knul-Linux.
Ah, ah.
Ich dachte...
Ich dachte, jetzt kommt...
Äh, ja.
Ja.
Oder System-D-Boot.
Man muss dazu sagen, es war die längste
Zeit nicht System-D.
Mittlerweile so seit, ich würd mal sagen,
seit 10 Jahren ungefähr ist es
mehr oder weniger
überall System-D.
Aber es gab eine Zeit
vor System-D,
da waren das alles Plaintext
Shell-Skripte, die beim Starten ausgeführt
wurden. Und eines der größten
Verkaufs- oder Selling-Points damals
von System-D war, es würde
das Booten
des PCs schneller machen oder
des Betriebssystems schneller machen,
weil man mit dem neuen Format
und Unit-Files und Dependency angeben
und sowas mehrere Dienste
parallel starten kann.
Da ist schon was dran.
Hat es sicherlich.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass heute,
wenn man mal
irgendwie, äh, alternatives...
Was hat, was hat Gentoo?
Gentoo hat ja kein System-D. Ich glaub, Gentoo ist so das letzte
ja, Mainstream kann man's
nicht mehr nennen. Das letzte OS, was
was haben die? RCInit?
oder sowas? Haben die bei
bei Gentoo? Ja, wahrscheinlich ist
das auch mittlerweile gar nicht mal so viel langsamer.
Der Vorteil war, aus meiner
Sicht, dass das weniger undurchsichtig
war als System-D.
Wobei System-D wiederum den
Vorteil hat, wenn man sich einmal an die ganze
Unit-File-Geschichte gewöhnt hat,
dann ist es erträglich.
Arctis hat das auch noch, okay.
Ich glaube, ich werde aber nie großer
Unit-File-Fan werden.
Was cool war, bei der alten
System, äh, bei dem System-D-Vorgänger,
RCLocal.
Es gab einfach eine Textdatei, da konnte
man reinschreiben, was man automatisch gestartet
haben möchte beim Rechner booten und fertig.
Das geht heute
natürlich mit System-D auch noch, da muss man aber extra
Unit-File anlegen. Und es gab
mal eine Zeit lang ein, äh,
RCLocal-System-D-Compatibility-Layer.
Der hat dann quasi System-D
RCLocal ausgeführt, aber den gibt's irgendwie
nicht mehr. Der ist nicht mehr standardmäßig dabei.
Was ich doof finde,
RCLocal war das Simpelste
überhaupt. Ich möchte diese drei Dinger
beim Booten ausführen, als Root wohlgemerkt.
Bäm, RCLocal eingetragen, geht.
Also,
ja, und das System-D-Ökosystem
ist ja mittlerweile auch komplett
aus dem Ruder gelaufen. Du hast
mittlerweile übrigens, wo wir gerade
dabei sind, System-D,
mittlerweile kann Linux sogar Plus-Screens.
Mittlerweile unterstützt
ja, das ist jetzt
ja, es gibt, es gibt
einen System-D Plus-Screen-Service
mittlerweile. Ja,
gibt es, gibt es zig, zig,
zig, zig Generators
für Unit-Files im Internet.
Ja.
Ähm, man muss aber,
man muss aber der Fairness halber jetzt sagen,
dass das sogar eine gute
Entwicklung ist, dass es einen Plus-Screen-Service
gibt für System-D.
Das liegt daran,
warte mal, ich probier, ich probier,
das mal zu erklären. Also,
ein Plus-Screen bei Windows,
zumindest, sagen wir mal, seit Windows,
mal kurz ein bisschen gedudelt an, ähm,
zumindest, sagen wir mal, seit Windows
äh, NT und Windows 2000
dann Mainstream-mäßig,
bedeutet ein Plus-Screen,
dein Betriebssystem ist in einem Zustand,
in dem es nicht mehr weiterarbeiten kann und es
stoppt jetzt. Bei Windows, ähm,
bei der DOS-Windows-Linie war das
noch ein bisschen anders. Ihr erinnert euch noch
vielleicht noch an Windows 95, Windows 98,
wo es ganz gerne mal sogar
Plus-Screens gab, wenn man das CD-Laufwerk
auf und zu gemacht hat. Da gab es dann ein Plus-Screen,
weil du die CD eingelegt hast und dann musstest du
einen Knopf drücken, um, um, ja,
we can try to continue, press a button.
Das ist spätestens
seit Windows 2000 nicht mehr so,
seitdem sie das vereint haben. Plus-Screen
bedeutet unter Windows heutzutage,
dein Betriebssystem ist,
nennen wir es mal, gecrashed.
Das stimmt zwar nicht so richtig,
genauer gesagt müsste man sagen,
dein Betriebssystem hat gecheckt,
dass es in einem Zustand ist, in dem es
nicht weiter machen kann und es
stoppt jetzt Sachen zu machen.
Es hört jetzt einfach auf an der Stelle
und macht nichts mehr.
Schreibt vielleicht noch einen Dump und dann
restartet es sich.
Also Plus-Screen ist nicht,
ist ganz streng genommen
nicht gleich Crash. Für dich als
Anwender ist es aber eigentlich egal. Crash
ist, das Ding freest.
Oder rebooted.
Plus-Screen ist nicht gleich
Crash. Zumindest wie dem auch sei,
sowas gab es unter Linux.
Kann man sich natürlich sagen,
ey ist doch geil, dass es keine Plus-Screen
unter Linux gibt. Naja, aber auch Linux
kann crashen. Beziehungsweise auch
Linux kann in einen Zustand kommen,
wo es nicht mehr
weiterarbeiten kann. Und da gab es
traditionell gesehen einen Kernel-Panic,
wenn Linux nicht mehr weiterarbeiten kann.
Das Problem ist nur gewesen,
an diesem Kernel-Panic,
dass du den Kernel-Panic nicht gesehen hast.
Du hast den Kernel-Panic nur
gesehen, wenn du
zufälligerweise hier
auf so einem
Linux
Kernel-Frame-Buffer-Interface
gewesen bist.
Ich glaube sogar nur auf dem ersten, da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Wenn der Kernel-Panic aufgetreten ist,
warst du hier in irgendeinem Desktop,
in irgendeiner
grafischen Oberfläche, konnte
dein Linux einfach freezen mit einem Kernel-Panic
und du hast den Kernel-Panic nie gesehen.
Was natürlich doof ist.
Du willst vielleicht schon wissen,
wenn dein Betriebssystem gecrashed ist.
Weil Linux eigentlich lange Zeit
nicht wirklich, oder ist es heute nicht,
das war nie akut,
weil Linux so gut wie nie gecrashed ist.
Aber es gab durchaus auch mal Kernel-Bugs
oder wirklich auch Hardware-Probleme,
wo Linux gecrashed ist, wo es nicht schlecht gewesen wäre,
das Ganze zu sehen.
Was jetzt eigentlich ist,
bzw. dass es jetzt gecrashed ist.
Und seitdem es das hier gibt,
hast du die Möglichkeit,
einen Plus-Screen dir anzeigen zu lassen.
Im Zweifelsfall auch von deinem
Kernel-Panic.
Auch auf einem grafischen Desktop.
Also das ist eigentlich
eine gute Sache, dass es jetzt
diesen Plus-Screen-Service gibt.
Weil der was fixt, was unter Linux
bisher nicht möglich war.
Was unter Linux nicht schlimm war,
weil Linux so gut wie nie gecrashed ist.
Aber wenn es gecrashed ist,
hast du gelitten.
Also eigentlich ist das eine gute Sache.
Natürlich waren die Diskussionen,
ich hab's auch auf Reddit und bei Foronix
das sind eh die geilsten,
gesehen.
Da haben sie sich drüber lustig gemacht.
Ah guck mal, SystemD führt jetzt auch
Plus-Screens unter Linux ein und sowas.
Was da wieder rum
gememt wird auf Reddit und so ist das eine.
Aber es ist in der Tat tatsächlich was ganz
sinnvolles, dass es das jetzt gibt.
Milchdieet, dankeschön für den Sub.
Soviel mal kleine
Sidetrack-Kurs
zu dieser Geschichte.
...
Nein, nein, Login-Screen
gibt's bei mir nicht.
So was brauch ich nicht.
Ich hab kein Login-Screen.
...
Du wirst etwas tun, das den Kernel beinhaltet, zum Beispiel ein File zu dem Filesystem schreiben.
Und das ist, wo System-Calls kommen.
In diesem C-Code hier, wirst du bemerken, dass ich ein Sys-Call zu Write mache,
das von Ring 3 nach Ring 0 transitioniert wird, um ein paar Texte zur Konsole zu vermitteln.
Aber Write ist nicht ein System-Call.
Es ist tatsächlich ein Wrapper, der von glibc verwendet wird,
das ist die gute neue Standard-Library für C,
und bietet alle Art von Wrappers für System-Calls, die fast alles auf deinem OS machen können.
Aber warte mal, was ist GNU?
Oh ne, jetzt geht's los.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Das mag ich an Fireship-Videos.
Ich bin mir manchmal nicht so sicher, ob das wirklich so ist, wenn er was sagt,
weil er biebt hier auch mal ganz gerne rum.
Aber das war mir bis jetzt gar nicht klar, dass deswegen eine Shell Shell heißt.
Different flavors of shells, but the most common is bash.
Let's say hello to the Linux kernel by running the GNU shell utility echo
and providing a string argument to it.
This command takes our message and prints it to the standard output.
Pretty simple, but what actually happened under the hood
is that a system call was made to the kernel,
which checked permissions and managed drivers
to turn those 1s and 0s into pixels on the screen.
As an end user though, I don't care.
My friend told me about a cool command called touch.
Er hat erklärt, warum Shell Shell heißt.
But I have no idea what it does.
The cool thing about Linux is that you can pull up the manual for any command
by hitting up my main man, man.
It looks like this command is used to create a new file.
Man, isn't that cool.
Let's go ahead and try it out now by creating a new text.
File.
It looks like nothing happened, but I promise it worked.
I can prove it by using the LS command to list out the files in this directory.
And there it is.
And we can read the file contents with the cat command.
But again, nothing happens because there's no data in this file.
However, there is a bunch of metadata like timestamps.
Warum?
Der das so so ich hab mir das jetzt nicht eins zu eins wiedergeben.
Da müsste ich jetzt zurückspulen.
Irgendwie, weil es deine user commands, Scheld eine Schelle ist zwischen dir und dem.
Körnel oder sowas.
Das wir natürlich drüber Gedanken gemacht, warum das so heißt.
Das rhymes mit Kat.
And when we run it, we know this file's birth time, when it was modified and when it was last accessed.
That's useful, but we can also get more information from the LS command by appending flags to it, like the L flag.
Beste Leute, beste Flex, beste Sache, LS aufzuholen, ist LS minus L A R T H macht folgendes.
Ich zeig's mal hier, gehen wir mal zu Images rein, macht folgendes.
Listet alle Dateien, also mit detaillierten Infos, alle Dateien und dann sortiert es das ganze nach der Zeit reverse und human readable.
Das bedeutet, ich bekomme, wie ihr seht, zeitlich das ganze aufsteigend, also sprich ganz unten sind die neuesten Dateien und die Größe der Datei.
Hier.
Die bekomme ich als human readable output, also sprich als Megabytes, Kilobytes, sonst wie und nicht als, äh, ja, womit's keiner was anfangen kann.
Was macht S? Weiß ich aus dem Kopf gar nicht.
Äh, ist S und H nicht das gleiche, dass quasi H S mit human readable ist?
Ja, also das, das ist mein, das ist so mein default LS Command.
LS lacht.
Man, LS.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt wird hier, jetzt wird hier mansplained auch noch.
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen, warum, äh, hab ich da kein Alias draufgesetzt?
Weil ich irgendwie keinen Bock habe, mich laufend an neue Alias zu gewöhnen, ja.
Manche machen LS oder LA oder sowas als Alias.
Das Problem, was ich mit Aliassen hab, wenn das so allgemeingültige Aliasse sind, wie beispielsweise für, wir listen Dateien auf der Shell auf,
dass du die dann bei dir hast und gewöhnst dich dran.
Hast du die dann, wenn du in Remote auf dem System bist, hast du die nicht.
Und deswegen habe ich für so Basic Dinger keine Aliasse.
Ja, für andere Sachen wie zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, meine, meine, ähm, Shell Config Edit hier, da habe ich ein Alias für, aber das will ich auch, soll man doch nicht machen.
To list more details and the H flag to make them human readable.
When we run that command, we can now see the exact size of every file.
And we can also combine flags in Linux to make this command more concise.
I don't want an empty file though, so I'm just going to remove it with the RM command.
The cool thing about the Linux Terminal is that it's really easy to combine commands.
Like I can take echo and use this angle bracket to redirect its output to a new file.
In addition, I can flip this angle bracket around to also redirect the input of a file.
That's cool, but pipes are even cooler.
They allow you to take the output of one command and pass it off to a new one, but pipes are even cooler.
They allow you to take the output and redirect the input of a file.
Guck mal, guck mal hier.
Redirect.
Das geht noch viel abgedreht.
Das geht noch viel abgedrehter.
Ich will das nicht übertreiben, aber man kann sogar solche Dinger machen hier.
Redirecten.
Man kann zum Beispiel Text ausgeben und in ein anderes Kommando füttern, was nur Dateien als Input nimmt.
Mit solchen Dingern.
Ganz, ganz abgedrehte Sachen.
Also generell, File- und Output-Input-Redirection is magic.
That's cool.
But pipes are even cooler.
They allow you to take the output of one command and pass it off to another command.
Like, for example, if we have a...
Ich kann das theoretisch mal zeigen.
Also sprich...
Also, was ihr wahrscheinlich kennt, ist sowas hier.
Grab.
Keine Ahnung.
Bash hier in dieser Datei.
Wird jetzt da drinnen gegrabbt.
Jetzt ist es ja so.
Wir machen das jetzt mal nur als Beispiel, nicht weil es wirklich sinnvoll ist.
Es gibt...
Text-Output, den man vielleicht an Programme füttern möchte, die als Input nur Dateien nehmen.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass Grab kein...
Also Grab akzeptiert auch auf Standard in Text.
Ja, also ich kann genauso gut sowas hier machen.
Es funktioniert genauso.
Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, wir haben jetzt nur ein Programm, was nur Dateien lesen kann.
Aber ich möchte in dieses Programm, was eigentlich nur Dateien lesen kann,
den Output von einem anderen Programm quasi reinbekommen.
Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit...
Und das mache ich so selten, deswegen bin ich mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, wie da die richtige Syntax ist.
War das so?
Nein, war es nicht.
So?
Oder so?
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das ging.
Ja, so war das.
So war das.
Genau.
Ja, so war das.
Und jetzt kann man...
Wobei, oder ist das jetzt Input Redirect?
Wartet mal.
Ne, ist es nicht.
Ist es nicht.
Ja.
Also, das nimmt jetzt das Output von hier, schreibt das in eine temporäre Datei und pipe dann das aus der temporären Datei da rein.
Also du kannst da ganz furchtbar wirre Dinger damit machen.
Wenn man es denn braucht.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen das und das?
Das sind komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Das eine hat mit dem anderen gar nichts zu tun.
Also, das hier...
Wobei...
Okay, okay.
Das kommt drauf an.
Also, das ist prinzipiell ein Pipe-Symbol.
Pipes verbinden Standard-Out mit Standard-In.
Also du kannst sowas hier machen.
Echo 1, 2, 3.
Gepiped nach grep lul.
Zum Beispiel.
Was jetzt nicht funktioniert, weil das nicht drinnen vorkommt.
So, das heißt, du verbindest den Standard-Input von grep mit dem Standard-Outpunkt.
Von Echo.
So, was das hier macht, ist tatsächlich ähnlich.
Das ist auch...
Das ist aber, glaube ich, eine Bash-Build-In-Geschichte.
Das ist Input oder Redirector.
Kannst du den Output...
Ne, warte mal.
Das geht ohne Pipe.
Es gibt einen Unterschied.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Unterschied.
Also, wo man das hier beispielsweise ganz gerne verwendet ist,
wenn man hier irgendwie sowas hat wie while, read, blub.
Echo, blub.
So, dann funzt...
Dann funzt das nicht.
So, und jetzt kann ich hier irgendwie sagen.
Redirect aus dieser Datei.
Ich kann ja aus dem Kopf nicht sagen, was genau der Unterschied ist
zwischen die Sachen Standard-In reinpipen oder Input-Redirect verwenden.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall einen Unterschied.
Ich glaube, das ist...
Es spart dir, einen zusätzlichen Prozess zu starten.
Ich glaube, das hier läuft Bash-Build-In,
wohingegen Cut-Pipe zwei Prozesse startet.
Ich glaube, das ist der große...
Ich glaube, das ist der Hauptunterschied.
Dass hier das deine Shell macht und du quasi nur das hier aufrufen musst
und bei dem anderen hier musst du zwei Programme starten.
In der Regel macht es wahrscheinlich nicht viel Unterschied.
Gibt bestimmt noch mehr Details, ja.
Das ist auch immer so ein Ding, was mich während meiner Ausbildung noch übelst getriggert hat.
Kennt ihr die Leute, die bei jedem Cat schreien, useless use of Cat?
Das sind keine...
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das...
Kann man nicht sagen, dass das irgendwelche Boomer-Leute sind, die einfach rückstehen...
Also...
Es gibt so ein Ding, was gerne erfahrene oder sich, sagen wir mal, selbst ernannte Linux-Pros,
was die sagen ist, wenn man sowas hier macht, ja.
Also...
Wir zeigen uns mal den Inhalt von der Datei an.
So.
Und wenn man das jetzt pipet nach grep, um da drin zu suchen,
zum Beispiel, okay, da ist sleep drin, ne.
Dann gibt es ganz viele Leute, die sagen, haha, useless use of Cat,
weil man könnte ja einfach auch das hier weglassen und das da hinten als File-Input schreiben.
Das ist richtig, aber trotzdem ist useless use of Cat in der Regel nicht useless.
Denn, was machst du denn jetzt, wenn du diesen Befehl dir der Reihe nach zusammenbauen willst, ja.
Du weißt ja vielleicht noch gar nicht, dass du das hier machen willst.
Du fängst an und sagst, aha, ich will mir die Datei ausgeben.
Ah, jetzt will ich vielleicht da drin was ersetzen.
Ah, jetzt will ich da...
Du baust das ja in der Regel der Reihe nach zusammen.
Und du fängst meistens mit einer Ausgabe an.
Natürlich kannst du danach hingehen und sagen, okay, ich lasse das Cat weg und schreibe jetzt das hinten dran.
Aber warum?
Ja, es spart vielleicht zwei Kilobyles.
Aber es ist im Kopf viel einfacher, sich so seine Pipe an Kommandos zusammenzubauen, anstatt sowas zu machen.
Und auch ganz ehrlich, in der Regel ist es ja so, du willst nicht nur eine Sache creppen,
sondern du willst meistens auch zwei, drei Sachen hintereinander creppen, ja.
Du willst zum Beispiel sagen, okay, ich will alle Dateien, die Set enthalten,
und dann alle Dateien, die, keine Ahnung, S enthalten, aber, ups, alle, die S enthalten,
aber ich will nicht die Sachen, die Sunset enthalten zum Beispiel.
Ja, das ist jetzt ein bisschen ein konstruiertes Beispiel.
So, und jetzt willst du wirklich, nachdem du das zusammengebaut hast, dann das hier erst da vorne löschen,
nur um hier das reinzuschreiben, damit du keinen useless use of Cat hast.
Das ist kompletter Blödsinn.
Also ich würde meinen Azubis auch nicht mit auf den Sack gehen.
Ich finde das hier vollkommen fein.
Und meiner Meinung nach ist das sogar besser lesbar als das.
Ja, da gibt's Leute, die spielen sich da immer gerne ein bisschen auf.
Nano.
Was ist denn hier los?
Das ist, das approve ich aber nicht, dass hier Dateien mit Nano editiert werden.
...most Linux distros.
At the top of the file we'll add a shebang that tells Linux to use the bash interpreter.
Then we can add as much bash code as we want here.
Like we might use echo and then read to read a value from the standard input,
and then echo to once again echo it back.
And now if we save this file, we can execute it by simply entering the file path in the terminal.
And that brings us to the...
Würdest du deinen Azubis heute zu Wim raten?
Ja, ich würde jedem, der sich damit beschäftigt, zu Wim raten.
Und ich meine damit nicht, Wim als hauptsächlichen Editor zu verwenden.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Ja, du musst nicht deine ganze Arbeit den ganzen Tag in Wim machen.
Du kannst ohne Probleme Visual Studio Code oder irgendwelche Chatbrain Tools verwenden.
Macht überhaupt kein Ding, mache ich auch.
Es ist nicht so, als würde ich 90% meines Tages, wenn ich was editiere, in Wim verbringen.
Aber Wim Basics ist eines der wichtigsten Sachen,
die du brauchst für Command Line Administration.
Du kannst dich darauf verlassen, dass auf jedem System in Wim drauf ist.
Nano nicht so sehr, auch wenn Nano bei den meisten drauf ist.
Aber grundsätzliche Ahnung von Wim.
Und du brauchst auch gar nicht viel Wissen.
Was brauchst du bei Wim wissen?
Du musst wissen, wie du das Ding aufmachst, wie du eine Datei öffnest.
Mittlerweile, muss man sagen, mit Wim ist das ja gar kein Problem.
Du kannst sogar mit Pfeiltasten navigieren mittlerweile.
Das ging ja früher gar nicht.
Früher musstest du mit HL und JK navigieren.
Wo manche Leute heute immer noch drauf schwören.
Und wisst ihr, was das Hauptargument der Hardcore Wim User ist?
Warum HJKL besser ist, als Pfeil hoch, Pfeil runter, links, rechts?
Ja, du kannst auch die Maus benutzen.
Aber die Maus habe ich ausgeschaltet.
Maus benutze ich in Wim nicht.
Maus finde ich einfach nur hinderlich in Wim.
Also das Hauptargument der Hardcore Wim-Hackermans ist, dass wenn du nicht Pfeiltasten verwendest, genau, dass du immer auf der Home-Row bist mit deinen Fingern.
Das Argument zählt für mich aber nicht, weil dein Browser ist auch nicht auf der Home-Row.
Dein Browser ist auf einem anderen Desktop und lässt sich mit der Maus am besten bedienen.
Und nachdem du eh mindestens 50% deiner Arbeit am Rechner im Browser bist, weil du irgendwas nachgucken musst, irgendwie was eintragen musst, irgendwas googeln musst, whatever, juckt das nicht.
Es juckt überhaupt nicht.
Ja, das geht.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz bedienst du einen Browser nach wie vor am besten mit der Tastatur.
Ich weiß, dass es Wim-Browser-Extensions gibt.
Da drückst du zum Beispiel F und dann zeigt es dann hier an.
Ich drücke jetzt, keine Ahnung, G, J, um hier hinzuspringen und so, das kenne ich.
Aber letztendlich, wenn ihr mal auf Webseiten geht, wie zum Beispiel YouTube oder Reddit oder sowas, die könnt ihr mit diesen Wim-Plugins nicht gescheit bedienen.
Also, ich will nicht sagen, dass man die nicht gescheit, das ist vielleicht falsch ausgedrückt, man kann die sicherlich bedienen mit den Wim-Plugins, ja.
Aber man ist mit einer Maus tatsächlich effektiver und schneller.
Gerade wenn das ein bisschen modernere Webseiten sind mit irgendwelchen Dropdowns und sonst was.
Jaja, es gibt Wim-Browser-Extensions.
Ich habe sogar mal jahrelang eine verwendet, ich weiß nicht mal, wie die hieß.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es Wimium war oder was gab es da noch?
Pentadactyl oder sowas gab es da noch und keine Ahnung.
Ich habe jahrelang, aber es war in Chrome eine, also es war nicht Pentadactyl, das ist glaube ich Firefox, war in Chrome.
Habe ich benutzt und man kommt sich natürlich super nice vor, wenn man jetzt F drückt und dann T, Z und springt da hin.
Aber ganz im Ernst, Leute, jede etwas komplexere Webseite lässt sich mit diesen Extensions kacke bedienen.
Deswegen, im Browser kommst du einfach nicht an der Maus vorbei.
Und nachdem man eh 50% seiner Zeit im Browser verbringt und immer was nachgucken muss, finde ich dieses Argument mit,
ja, hier muss man ja seine Finger quasi von der Mitte der Tastatur bewegen, um an die Pfeiltasten zu greifen, einfach nicht mehr zeitgemäß.
Und ansonsten?
Was muss man in Wim sonst noch wissen?
Man muss wissen, wie man rauskommt.
Bei Emacs kriegst du dumme Finger, bei Wim ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so sehr, weil Wim keine Tastenkombinationen braucht.
Also bei Wim musst du nicht Ctrl, Alt, Alt-G-R, Post-1 und P zusammendrücken oder sowas.
Sondern Wim hat ja diesen Wim Edit, Editier Language, dass du eigentlich so gut wie alles mit Tastenabfolgen machen kannst.
Du wechselst ja nicht andauernd hin und her.
Doch, machst du.
Du guckst nach.
Guck mal.
Also, nehmen wir mal irgendein aktuelles Beispiel.
So, ja, keine Ahnung.
Irgendwelche Frontend-Geschichten.
So, ich weiß jetzt beispielsweise nicht.
So, ich hab ein schönes Beispiel.
Äh, was hab ich denn hier eigentlich auf?
Das wollte ich überhaupt nicht machen.
Das falsche Project.
Äh, hier.
Don't Save.
Ja, nehmen wir mal das hier als Beispiel.
Mal angenommen, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man hier Props macht in Svelte 5, weil Svelte 5 neu ist.
Also geh ich in Google und sag hier Svelte 5 Props.
Okay, aha, aha, dann weiß ich wie das geht.
Dann copy-paste ich mir hier beispielsweise das Beispiel hier raus rein.
Äh, pass das an, so.
Und dann stell ich fest, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich will ja eine Variable.
Nicht const, sondern let.
Aber alle anderen will ich, will ich const.
Also gehst du wieder im Browser und suchst danach.
Du bist im Prinzip, du bist permanent.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch aussieht.
Wenn ich irgendwas programmiere und irgendwas mache, ich switche in der Regel zu,
die Hälfte der Zeit ist bei mir switchen zwischen Browser und Editor.
Und wenn es nicht zwischen Browser, es ist drei Sachen, drei Sachen wird geswitcht.
Es wird zwischen Browser geswitcht, zwischen Editor und einer Command Line,
wo ich irgendwas ausprobieren kann.
Und dementsprechend finde ich das Argument mit Home-Row, das, das, das zieht halt einfach nicht.
Wenn man 95% seiner Zeit nur in Vim ist, dann mag das Sinn machen.
Aber das ist man halt nicht.
Du siehst nicht, wie die Maus den Work...
Ja, weil du deinen Browser nicht bedienen kannst, gescheit ohne Maus.
Hast du mal YouTube mit so einem Vim-Plugin versucht zu bedienen?
Oder Reddit?
Oder irgendeine halbwegs moderne, dynamische Seite?
Das funktioniert nicht gescheit.
Okay, Skylone kann das.
Mag sein.
Ich kann das nicht.
Und ich habe das ausprobiert und ich habe diese Sachen wieder aus meinem Browser verbannt,
weil es einfach nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Also ich finde, das zählt nicht.
Letztendlich macht das so, wie ihr das haben wollt.
Aber die Ersparnis von HJKL vs. Pfeiltasten,
wenn man eh laufend zur Maus greift für den Browser...
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich finde das...
Und spätestens, spätestens wenn es um, wo das ja auch teilweise herkommt,
spätestens wenn es um Frontend-Entwicklung geht, wenn du HTML und sowas machst
und hier nebenbei ein Browser-Fenster offen hast, wo du deine Anwendung ausprobieren musst,
dann ist das eh Schwachsinn, weil dann ist es komplett offensichtlich,
dass wenn das jetzt deine Webseite ist, die du hier editierst,
dass du laufend speichern musst, rübergehen musst im Browser
und gucken, ob das funktioniert, was du gebaut hast.
Da brauchst du die Maus.
Also mit Frontend-Entwicklung ist es auf jeden Fall kompletter Schwachsinn
und ich finde, für die anderen Sachen macht es auch keinen Sinn.
Ja.
Also das ist, finde ich, ist overrated, outdated, jebaited.
Wo sind wir denn eigentlich?
Und ansonsten, was muss man eigentlich großartig in Vim wissen?
Wir probieren das jetzt mal aus.
Es ist schon eine Weile her, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
wo ich Browser-Plugins verwendet habe,
für Vim-Browser-Plugins verwendet habe, für Firefox.
Aber wir machen das jetzt mal.
Mal gucken, ob das noch so funktioniert, wie das vor ein paar Jahren funktioniert hat.
So.
Jetzt haben wir es installiert.
So, gut.
Also, dann gehen wir mal hier hin.
So, Google.
Google.
So.
Und jetzt?
Okay, bis jetzt brauche ich es nicht.
device-welt-5-props.
Früher musste man F drücken.
Okay, das geht immer noch.
F drücken.
Das geht immer noch.
So, okay.
Das geht noch ohne Maus.
Ja.
So.
Jumpen wir mal da hin.
sm.
Runes.
Okay, jetzt will ich nach unten scrollen, auf der Seite.
Da geht es schon los, wie scrolle ich gescheit nach unten.
Der Input-Fokus ist nicht nach unten.
Wie scrolle ich nach unten?
Maus. Jetzt kommen wir nicht mit Bild
hoch, Bild runter. Leertaste
geht nicht. Page down geht
nicht. Ctrl-D
macht einen Bugmark.
Escape-J geht nicht.
Es geht nicht, weil
der Fokus der Seite hier ist
und nicht hier. Wenn ich hier reinklicke,
geht es. Der Standardfokus
der Seite, wenn sie geladen wird, ist aber hier.
Tja, doof, hä?
Geht nicht ohne Maus.
Erstes Beispiel,
ja, erstes Beispiel.
Ah, okay, jetzt funktioniert es. Nachdem ich einmal in die Mitte
geklickt habe, funktioniert es.
Nachdem ich einmal in die Mitte geklickt habe,
funktioniert es. Aber ich glaube,
das versinnbildlicht ja schon
einmal, oder das demonstriert ja schon
einmal ganz gut, mein Problem mit diesen
Vim-Browser-Plugins.
Bei der ersten Seite, die ich geöffnet habe, konnte ich nicht
mal runterscrollen.
Ohne, dass ich auf gut Glück tappe oder einmal hier
reinklicke.
Dein Browser ist einfach nicht für
Tastaturbedienung gemacht.
Guck, jetzt scrollt es
wieder nicht.
Ich drücke J, es scrollt nicht. Es scrollt
erst, nachdem ich einmal in die Mitte
geklickt habe. Jetzt kann ich mit J
scrollen. Weil der Fokus
auf der linken Seite ist.
Ja, das ist schön, aber die
Webseite,
es ist nicht, dass ich nicht weiß, welcher Knopf scrollt.
Durch den
Fokus des Elements auf der Navigationsseite
links ist nicht
der mittlere Part im
Fokus, mit dem ich scrollen könnte.
Also, erst beste Webseite
demonstriert schon mal wieder ganz gut, dass
diese Browser-Plugins einfach nicht
das Wahre sind. Browser sind
nicht für Tastaturbedienung
ausgelegt. Und spätestens
ich sage nicht,
dass es nicht
nützlich sein kann,
so ein Browser-Plugin zu finden. Sicherlich,
es ist mit Sicherheit nützlich,
wenn ich jetzt, also wäre für mich auch nützlich,
ich bin hier irgendwie am Editieren, switch jetzt
rüber in den Browser.
Jetzt hat er wieder das Side-Net richtig geladen.
Und will jetzt hier zum Beispiel,
sagen wir mal, keine Ahnung,
was auch immer
er jetzt gemacht hat, keine Ahnung,
ich will jetzt hier, keine Ahnung, dahin switchen.
Es ist sicherlich cool, Links öffnen
zu können, ohne mit der Maus draufklicken zu müssen.
Das ist schon praktisch, aber man hat schon
beim erstbesten Beispiel gesehen, dass halt Webseiten,
so und jetzt muss ich wieder zur Maus greifen,
was halt komplett
dieses Argument entkräftet
mit, ja,
die Arrow-Keys sind
böse, weil die Arrow-Keys
deine Hand
zwei Zentimeter in die falsche Richtung bewegen
auf der Tastatur.
In Wirklichkeit musst du laufen,
deine Hand mindestens 15 Zentimeter in die falsche
Richtung bewegen, um zur Maus zu greifen,
dass du deinen Browser ordentlich bedienen kannst.
Die Move-Exchangen.
Deswegen habe ich aufgehört,
Vim-Browser-Extensions zu benutzen,
weil Webseiten einfach nicht dafür gemacht sind.
So schaut's aus.
Die ultimative Wahrheit, Leute, nur hier im Stream.
Warum man die Maus nicht benutzen sollte,
das ist Sache, nicht ich,
aber es gibt ein paar Hardcore-Vim-User,
die sagen, es wäre
unergonomisch,
wenn man
die Pfeiltasten benutzt.
Und ich sage,
die Pfeiltasten machen es auch nicht fett,
wenn man eh laufen zur Maus greifen muss
für seinen Browser.
Es ist viel Geschmackssache dabei.
Ja, ach ja, ich weiß, wo wir dabei gewesen sind.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, ja,
das verstehe ich auch.
Ja, ist auch so ein Ding, was man bei Vim noch wissen muss,
das Wichtigste bei Vim, wie man den beendet,
Vim beendet, ist relativ easy.
Erstmal, falls man vorher Mist gemacht hat,
merkt euch mal Folgendes.
Wenn ihr in Vim seid, irgendwie doof rumgeklickt habt,
und jetzt nicht mehr wisst, wie ihr rauskommt, ja,
drückt einfach ein paar Mal ESC,
nicht das Mehrfach-ESC, was bringt,
aber da könnt ihr sicher sein,
ihr macht sonst nichts anderes.
Drückt ein paar Mal ESC,
und dann sagt ihr einfach Doppelpunkt Q.
Und am besten Ausrufezeichen, dass ihr nichts speichert drinnen.
Es gibt zig Varianten, Vim zu beenden,
die ihr nicht beenden könntet.
Die komplizierteste und obskurste Variante,
die ich kenne, Vim zu beenden,
mit, wohlgemerkt,
Vim-Bordmitteln, ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwie,
äh, ne, Vim-Killen oder sowas.
Also die obskurste Variante,
Vim-Bordmittel, die ich kenne, ist,
äh, Shift-ZZ.
Warum das ein Ding ist,
keine Ahnung, aber es ist ein Ding, ja.
Du kannst Q beenden,
kannst X machen, kannst W machen,
kannst WQ machen, kannst Ausrufezeichen machen,
alles mögliche.
Es gibt hunderte Varianten, Vim zu beenden.
Gibt's wahrscheinlich, gibt's wahrscheinlich
sogar ganze GitHub-Repos,
die alle Arten, Vim zu beenden,
irgendwie zusammentragen.
Aber
Shift-ZZ ist die Build-In-Variante,
die ich am abgedrehtesten
finde. Warum auch immer Shift-ZZ
funktioniert, ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, das meiste, also die meiste Zeit,
die ich Vim benutze, ist X.
Ich mach meistens X,
weil X ist speichern und schließen
in einem.
Also im Prinzip ist X, die abkühlen, die
Abkürzung von, äh,
WQ. Und ansonsten muss man
bei Vim, ehrlich gesagt, bei
modernen
Vims, ja, wo Pfeiltasten
und alles gehen, gar nicht so viel
wissen. Man muss wissen, wie man eine Datei
aufmacht, so. Man muss wissen, wie man rauskommt,
so. Und man muss wissen,
dass man, wenn man was editieren will,
vorher I drücken muss, dann was
schreiben und dann Escape und dann
raus, beziehungsweise
write und dann raus.
Das ist eigentlich alles. Mehr muss man
Vim nicht wissen. Mit der Zeit kommt
man vielleicht hinter so ein paar,
so ein paar Geheimnisse. Ja, zum Beispiel,
wenn ich jetzt in dieser Zeile bin und alles
ändern möchte, was zwischen den
Anführungszeichen steht, also sprich
alles, was hier zwischen dem und dem
steht, dann kann ich zum Beispiel
sowas machen. Das ist,
wenn ihr das hier drückt, C
I
Anführungszeichen.
Change inner, kann man sich ganz gut merken.
Change inner und dann nimmt er alles,
was... Das sind dann so ein paar spezielle
Vim-Hackerman-Sachen, die man mit der Zeit lernt.
Oder zum Beispiel auch, wenn man hier eine Zahl
stehen hat, ups, ah,
dass man das Ganze mit Ctrl-A
increasen kann und mit Ctrl-X,
wo ich aber, äh,
Panel schließen auf meinem Terminal draufgelegt hat,
wo man sieht, wie oft ich dieses Feature in Vim
verwende, äh, decreasen kann.
Copy und Paste in Vim
ist in der Tat auch sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftig, deswegen
gibt es noch sowas wie Set Number,
was hier neben die, äh,
die Teilnummern einblendet. Das Problem,
ist jetzt, wenn man jetzt was copy-pasten
will aus Vim, das Problem hat
bestimmt auch schon der ein oder anderen gehabt, wenn ich jetzt was
copy-pasten will, dann...
Ich probier
keinen anderen Command-Line-Editor aus, weil Vim
überall drauf ist und ich an...
mich an Vim gewöhnt habe und an Vim
gewöhnt bleiben will, weil ich die Hälfte
des Tages auf Remote System bin.
So, ähm...
Wenn man jetzt hier copy-pastet,
hat man diesen Mist mit drinnen.
Es gibt zwei Varianten, das Ganze zu umgehen.
Es gibt die Noob-Variante, die ich persönlich auch
verwende, also Set No Number,
ausgeschrieben,
dann entfernt
das temporär oder permanent, je nachdem
was man in seiner Datei, in seiner Config schreibt,
dieses Ding und man kann copy-pasten.
So, dann
gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, das ist, das ist aber
richtig kacke, das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht,
man kann, äh, man kann Maus-Mode
irgendwie einschalten und es ist so,
guck mal, hier, keine Ahnung,
ich weiß nicht, wer so gestört ist und Maus, äh,
Maus in Vim verwendet,
das kommt aus, so.
Also, das funktioniert oder
aber, was auch funktioniert,
ihr könnt auch V drücken,
das markieren, was ihr haben wollt
und jetzt kommt der Trick.
Jetzt kommt der Trick.
Wenn ihr was kopieren wollt oder größere Absätze
in Vim kopieren wollt, so,
ihr markiert das und drückt Y.
Y ist quasi sowas wie Steuerung
C in Vim. Und mit P
könnt ihr das Ganze dann wieder einfügen.
Das Problem ist jetzt nur, dass das Ganze jetzt
nicht im System, mach mal kurz zu,
dass das Ganze nicht im System
Clipboard landet.
Damit die Sachen im System Clipboard landen,
kommt ganz
wirre, wirre Shortcut zu,
da markiert man das und jetzt drückt
man Anführungszeichen
plus
und jetzt
Y.
Und jetzt ist der Kram, wie ihr hier seht,
äh, oder auch nicht,
ich glaub ich hab einfach mein Clipboard nicht,
mein System Clipboard nicht aktiviert,
jetzt ist der Kram im System Clipboard,
das was ihr woanders auch wieder pasten könnt,
was nicht funktioniert hat.
Warum auch immer.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube einfach, weil ich ihn nicht aktiviert hab.
Aber da, da wird's mir
dann auch zu abgedreht, deswegen
benutze ich teilweise
einfach die Noob-Variante und copy-paste
übers Terminal und fertig.
Und nicht mit Vim-Build-In.
Also das würde ich nicht machen. Aber einfach Dateien editieren
und jetzt kommen wir mal zum Vorteil
Vim vs. Nano.
Vim ist überall drauf.
Das ist tatsächlich der einzig große Vorteil,
den das hat. Für jemand, der echt ab und zu mal
nur ein paar Textdateien editieren will und sonst nix,
wär Nano genauso gut.
Aber Vim hat den Vorteil, Vim ist überall drauf.
Also das einzige,
wo kein Vim drauf ist oder VI drauf ist,
ist glaub ich irgendwelche,
ich glaube sogar,
ich glaube sogar das Net Install
Debian hat nen VI drauf.
Ich glaube das einzige,
was du findest, sind irgendwelche Containerdistributionen
so Alpine oder sowas, die haben das nicht.
Aber du hast sogar auf Cisco Switch
nen Vim drauf bzw. nen VI.
Also VI-Bedienung
bringt einem auf
99% aller Systeme,
die irgendwie auf irgendwas
Unix, Linux-artigem
basieren weiter.
Nano nicht.
Deswegen würde ich auch jedem
Azubi heute noch sagen, Basic Vim
Bedienung muss man kennen.
Und ich meine nicht damit,
dass man täglich in Vim so alles machen soll,
was man so macht. Das reicht schon.
Was wir uns angeguckt haben.
Man muss in der Lage sein,
in Vim eine Datei zu öffnen, zu editieren
und zu speichern. Mehr nicht.
Die ganzen anderen Vim-Hackerman-Geschichten
sind vollkommen egal.
Jetzt gucken wir uns aber das Video mal fertig an.
Ach ja, wo wir gerade bei Vim-Dingern gewesen sind,
muss ich euch jetzt an der Stelle auch noch zeigen,
weil das auch was sehr Praktisches ist,
wo viele Leute Probleme mit haben.
Ihr könnt in Vim
Zeilen markieren.
Und zwar, so wie ich es eben gezeigt habe,
oder, also es gibt
drei Varianten, wie ihr Zeilen markieren könnt.
Oder wie ihr Sachen markieren könnt in Vim.
Es ist einmal V für Visual Mode.
Und das ist so das Klassische, was man kennt.
Man markiert quasi das,
wo man mit dem Cursor hingeht.
Wenn ich das jetzt markiere und D drücke,
dann ist das weg.
Dann gibt es Shift-V.
Shift-V ist Zeilenweise.
Auch ganz praktisch.
Und dann gibt es was,
das ist Control-V.
Das ist dann quasi
Vertikal.
Control-V,
das ist was sehr Nices,
weil man damit zum Beispiel
Einrückungen machen kann.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ich möchte alle diese Sachen hier
eins weiter einrücken.
Die Noobs würden jetzt so machen.
Oder vielleicht die bisschen advancederen Noobs
würden
letztes Kommando Repeat verwenden, oder so.
Aber,
die viel einfachere Variante
ist, diese Zeilen
zu markieren, und zwar
vertikal zu markieren,
Shift-I zu drücken,
zwei Leerzeichen einzufügen,
und dann Escape zu drücken.
Ich hoffe, man konnte mir folgen.
Du kannst dann nämlich
den Edit-Vorgang,
wenn du das gemacht hast,
kannst du den Edit-Vorgang
an mehreren Zeilen wiederholen.
Das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel.
Das Einrücken geht tatsächlich
deutlich einfacher mit,
was ist das?
Größerzeichen.
Aber das war jetzt nur ein Beispiel.
Irgendwie
an dieser Stelle, was
einfügen wollt,
könnt ihr das so machen.
Man kann
die Sudo-Privileges
natürlich nicht selber granten.
Das wäre ja ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge.
Es sei denn, du hast
Root-Login schon auf der Kiste.
Wir sind in unserer Home-Direktorie,
was ein persönlicher Arbeitsplatz ist
für den User, den du mitgebracht hast.
Wir könnten hier eine neue Direktorie machen,
mit dem Make-Jer-Kommand,
dann verwenden wir CD, um Direktoren zu ändern.
Nun verwenden wir pwd, um die aktuelle
funktionierende Direktorie zu printen.
Aber jetzt gehen wir außerhalb unseres Hauses
in den Ruf des Filesystems
und verwenden CD-Slasher.
Wenn du hier LS klickst, findest du
eine Menge kritische Direktoren,
die du kennen musst.
CD enthält Konfigurations-File
und VAR enthält Log-File.
Die interessanteste Direktorie hier ist bin,
die deine Binarien besitzt.
Und sbin für System-Binarien.
Wenn du einen Command wie LS runntest,
schaut Linux für eine exekutierbare Binarie
auf deinem System, um zu exekutieren.
Die Sache ist, dass Binarien nicht nur hier leben,
sondern auch unter der
User-System-Resourcen-Direktorie
und potenziell wo auch immer du willst.
Ja, Binaries, gerade wenn man
npm-Sachen installiert hat,
dann ist das auch mal ganz gerne unter
bin, bin, .n, p, n,
p, n, bin, po, also alles mögliche.
...want on the file system.
And that begs the question,
how does Linux know where to find the right binary?
Well, that's where path comes in.
It's a special environment variable
that contains paths to directories
separated by colons.
Mein path ist mittlerweile so lang,
dass ich mir das gar nicht merken kann.
Whatever.
Was da alles für ein Schrott drinne ist, man!
When you enter a command,
path for a matching binary in each directory and execute the first one it finds its value is set
on the system by default but it's common to customize it by using the export keyword which
will set the value for an environment variable the most common technique is to update the path for an
individual user by customizing the bash rc file which itself is a script that will run before
every terminal session and now that we're inside this file we can also do things like customize
the ps1 environment variable to change the terminal prompt to look more like a mega hardcore
hacker when coding at starbucks which is a proven way to attract a mate as a linux user but now it's
time to talk about file permissions use ls flag l on any file to view permissions and notice these
cryptic nine characters these are called symbolic permissions das hat mich als ich neu war da kann
ich mich noch dran erinnern also als ich als meine ausbildung damals angefangen hat hat mich das echt
verwirrt vor allem weil du ja nicht also zumindest damals so wie mir das die leute damals gezeigt haben
nicht etwa angibst ich will write für den user haben sondern weil du sowas angibst wie keine ahnung
774 oder sowas das ist das ist schon ein bisschen kryptisch mittlerweile mache ich tatsächlich auch
lieber in der besser lesbaren variante also man kann ja man kann ja zum beispiel wenn man hier eine
datei hat hier irgendwie nach tmp touch blub so
jetzt haben wir eine datei blub die hat standardmäßig hier was ist das 6 644 ist das das problem ist
dass das 644 es ist absolut nicht obvius 644 setzt sich daraus zusammen weil ried gleich vier
ist execute gleich eins und wright gleich gleich zwei so und das heißt wenn du wenn es für den user
read write ist dann ist das 6 weil wright plus read das in binary flex weil wright plus read sind 6
also das was die datei berechtigung hier oben sind im prinzip 644 weil wright ergibt 6 nur
read ergibt 4 und nur read ergibt 4 das heißt wenn ich das jetzt die berechtigung setzte auf
die datei dann sind es exakt die gleichen danach als davor guckt so also das 644
das problem ist das ist super verwirrend wenn man sich das nicht wenn man das nicht nicht mal
verinnerlicht hat ja ich kann euch das zum beispiel wenn ich 777 vergebe dann habe ich
read write execute für user ach so das kommt ja auch noch dabei diese dinge sind aufgeteilt in
dreier blöcke diese dinge sind aufgeteilt in dreier blöcke die ersten drei sind für user die nächsten
drei sind für die gruppe und die nächsten drei sind für alle anderen also 777 bedeutet im endeffekt
anstatt multivariate ist 3 und und und re ist also equally excuse für diese dinge da nennt man also
ja das ist also so eine dinge re write execute füge den user retweet exekute für die gruppe
re-write exekute für alle anderen auch also das ist bis hier das ist ein bisschen kryptisch wer
sind alle anderen alle anderen sind nicht der user beziehungsweise leute die nicht in der gruppe sind
Ja, was man nämlich auch machen kann, also wir setzen jetzt die Datei mal, keine Ahnung, hier auf 0, 0, 0.
0, 0, 0 hat die jetzt, also früher hat man gar keine Rechte drauf.
Was ich jetzt, was ich persönlich ein bisschen schöner finde, ist mittlerweile CRMOD, dass du jetzt sagst, der User soll bekommen Write-Rechte.
Guck, das finde ich persönlich etwas logischer als in dem Fall jetzt 4, 0, 0.
Du sagst, User bekommt Write-Rechte, du kannst sagen, Gruppe bekommt, äh, achso, das muss man, das muss man auseinanderschreiben, nee, warte, wie geht das jetzt?
Das meiste sind immer nur Einzelne, ja, Gruppe, Gruppe, Gruppe bekommt Write-Rechte.
Man kann das irgendwie auch kombinieren, da bin ich aber zu low IQ für, ich glaube, ich kann sagen, ja, ich kann sagen, User Group plus W, das funktioniert auch.
User und Group plus W.
Man kann übrigens auch sagen, Minus W, dann wird das wieder entfernt.
Das finde ich persönlich ein bisschen einfacher, allerdings, wenn man tatsächlich hardcoded die Datei auf einen speziellen Wert setzen will, ist das hier immer noch sinnvoll, weil hier löschst du und fügst ja nur Einzelrechte hinzu.
Wenn du wirklich sicher gehen willst, diese Datei hat 644, dann kommt man da nicht dran vorbei.
Es ist echt ein bisschen undurchsichtig, aber mittlerweile benutze ich lieber das hier.
Genau.
Das würde, das würde funktionieren, dass du jetzt hier sagst, oder kann man, achso, klar, ja, genau, kannst du das, also irgendwie sagst du hier, ich will, dass sie alle Read-Write da drauf haben.
Das ist im Prinzip genau das Gleiche, wie wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, 666 zum Beispiel.
Egal.
Nur mal so eingeworfen nehmen.
Das dritte Triplet ist der Verbraucher, das Mitte, der Gruppe und das letzte Triplet ist für alle anderen.
Jeder hat eine Letter, die die Privilegien von Read, Write und Execute betrifft.
Wenn die Letter präsent ist,
bedeutet das, dass man zugelassen wird, aber wenn es eine Warnung gibt, bedeutet das, dass die Behörde negiert wird.
Diese können auch als Zahlen und Oktalnotationen dargestellt werden, z.B.
777 lässt irgendjemand etwas zu einem File tun.
Ich weiß, 777 ist gut auf Slot-Maschinen, aber in Linux ist es generell eine schlechte Idee, weil du immer folgen willst, das Prinzip der leistbaren Privilegien.
Begründe Zugang zu Dingen nur, wenn es notwendig ist und vertraue niemandem.
Nun, du kannst die Behörden auf einem File mit dem Chmod-Kommand modifizieren, wie hier.
Ich benutze es, um Zugang zu einem Dokument für alle zu bieten.
Wir können auch die Behörde eines Files mit Chone oder die Gruppen mit Chagroup modifizieren.
Und jetzt, dass wir wissen, was all diese Dinge bedeuten, sind die Verbindungen nicht so kryptisch.
Nun, jedes Mal, wenn du ein Kommand oder ein Programm ausübst,
entsteht ein Prozess auf der CPU, das durch den Linux-Kernel gestaltet wird.
Du kannst diese Prozesse mit dem Psst-Kommand beobachten.
Und bemerke, wie jeder hat eine unique Prozess-ID,
mit dem User, der sie erschaffen hat.
Oder besser noch, benutze Htop, um einen interaktiven Breakthrough zu bekommen.
In den meisten Versionen von Htop kann Htop auch I-O-Auslastung und nicht nur CPU-Auslastung und RAM.
Ich weiß nicht, bei welcher Version sie das eingeführt haben, aber das ist sehr nice.
Wobei, die coolen Leute verwenden ja mittlerweile Btop.
Das sieht dann nochmal stylischer aus.
Und hat so ein bisschen Doom-like-Menü.
Aber ich persönlich verwende Htop, ich verwende keinen Btop.
Ja, für Netzwerkauslastung, das stimmt, dafür ist das ganz praktisch.
Aber ich bin Htop-Enjoyer.
Mir ist Btop zu übertrieben viel auf einmal.
Ist Btop in Perl?
Ne, Btop ist glaube ich irgendein Python-Tool.
Oder?
Gucken wir mal, was es ist.
Ist es irgendein Binary?
Ok, GitHub, Btop.
Ist ja alles Open Source, kann man nachgucken.
Es ist...
C++!
Weg.
Gleich wieder weg.
Warum gucken wir uns das nicht an?
Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja
is just a complete operating system
built on the Linux kernel.
And each distro has a highly opinionated
set of default software for their target
audience. Some are designed for beginners,
others for hardcore hackers, and
everything in between. Distros can have
different package managers to install new software
like APT, Yum, and
Pac-Man, and they might also have different release
schedules. Like some have a predictable
fixed release date, while others have ruling
releases that keep their software on the cutting
edge at all times. And one thing we didn't even
talk about is desktop environments.
If using Linux as a PC,
your distro will have a default desktop environment
like Gnome or KDE Plasma,
and that makes a huge difference in the experience.
Some distro families you should know about
include Slackware, the original
gangster from the 90s, Debian,
the most popular distro overall,
famous for its open philosophy and ease of
use, Red Hat, the distro of choice
in enterprise for...
...its long-term support plans,
and finally, the Arch family.
If someday you find your...
Wie? Einfach nur Arch family?
Ich dachte, das wundert mich
jetzt, dass er sich das entgehen lässt.
...self saying, I use Arch, by the way.
Ah, okay, das musste ja noch kommen.
And ironically, it means you've embraced the paradox
of complexity and simplicity.
And your operating system is no longer
just a tool, but a reflection of your own
dominance and mastery over the digital
world. Thanks for watching. Check out
the full course if you want to go deeper. Das hätte mich jetzt auch sehr...
Sehr gewundert. Ups. Das hätte mich jetzt auch
sehr gewundert, wenn er das sich durch die Lappen
gehen lässt. Übrigens,
wo wir gerade bei Systemmonitoring
Tools, Auslastungstools
gewesen sind. Ich persönlich bin
D-Stat-Enjoyer.
Auch wenn ich es jetzt hier irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht installiert habe.
Haben die das umbenannt?
Gibt es das nicht mehr? Ach, deswegen
habe ich das vielleicht nicht mehr installiert.
Ich glaube, das heißt jetzt anders, ne?
Warum gibt es denn das
nicht mehr? Aha, weil es
erschieft ist.
Okay.
Duel ist es jetzt. Ja, okay.
Deswegen, das war gut.
Das mag ich.
Witzigerweise auf
Debian gibt es das noch.
Auf Red Hat System gibt es das auch noch.
Und ich finde das ganz praktisch.
Nicht, weil du da irgendwie jetzt so wahnsinnig viel
mehr sehen würdest als in D-Stat.
Aber, weil sich der Output
relativ gut locken lässt.
Deswegen mag ich das.
Manchmal
auch in Zeiten von, man hat
in den Systemen hunderttausend Metrics.
Manchmal ist es nicht verkehrt,
die 0815
Basic-Werte wie CPU-Usage,
Disk-Usage und Net-Usage und Load
und solche Geschichten, zusammen mit der
Uhrzeit, mal eine Viertelstunde,
wenn du auf irgendwas wartest, in der Textdatei
zu schreiben und dann zu gucken, wann war denn was.
Man braucht es nicht mehr oft, aber wenn man
es braucht, D-Stat ist sehr, sehr nützlich.
Ja. Und
dadurch, dass das
so sekundenweise, das zeilenweise
aktualisiert wird, finde ich, sieht man da manchmal
Sachen auch einfacher und schneller.
Gerade wenn es um
Disk-Usage und Netzwerk-Bandbreite geht.
Wenn das mal kurz
spiked und du nicht genau weißt,
was Sache ist, finde ich D-Stat eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Wir haben auf der Arbeit
auch nur Red Hat, weil
Enterprise und die, die ein bisschen
Geld in den Rachen schmeißen wollen,
gibt es nur Red Hat.
Ich selbst verwende überall,
wo ich kann, für meine Systeme,
die ich zum
Arbeiten benutze.
Also nicht die Server, sondern
die, die ich benutze als quasi
Workstation
und Desktop. Da verwende ich so weit wie möglich
Arch-Linux drauf, by the way.
Warum hat sich Red Hat, ja wahrscheinlich
wegen Support-Verträgen
und weil es die schon ewig gibt
und wahrscheinlich, weil die ein nerviges Sales-Team
haben, was den Leuten immer was aufschwätzt.
Was ist die Alternative?
Suse Enterprise,
Keg W, bloß nicht
und vielleicht noch Ubuntu.
Da würde ich sogar
Ubuntu vorziehen.
Also ich persönlich würde Debian vorziehen,
aber im Business-Enterprise-Umfeld sind die Leute
ja der Meinung, wenn wir keinen
Support-Vertrag haben, können wir es nicht verwenden.
Warum, weiß man nicht. Man möchte halt gerne
ein paar Millionen Geld, ein paar Millionen
spenden an Red Hat.
Der Red Hat Support ist
gar nicht so
useless, muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen.
Nee, also der Red Hat Support
ist, sagen wir mal, weniger useless als
der Microsoft Azure oder der,
ähm, Oracle Support.
Der Red Hat Support ist gar nicht
so... Ich hab, ich hab mal, ich bin
zu weit vom Schreibtisch weggelaufen
und hab
das Mikro rausgezogen.
Ja, aber der Red Hat Support ist gar
nicht so schlecht. Der ist schlecht,
aber nicht so schlecht wie Microsoft und Oracle.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich
bin der Meinung, dass viele
Geld, was an Red Hat überwiesen wird
für Support, ist absolut
rausgeschmissenes Geld und nicht gerechtfertigt.
Das heißt, leistungsmäßig,
aber wie das halt im Business Enterprise
Umfeld so ist, Supportverträge
sind eher zum
Beruhigen da, als um wirklich Probleme
zu lösen. Genau.
Genau für solche Sachen,
das ist ein gutes Beispiel, genau für solche Sachen.
Da könnt ihr nämlich sagen, ja, wir haben
einen Call bei Red Hat aufgemacht
und Case bei Red Hat aufgemacht oder wie auch immer das der
jeweilige Anbieter nennt.
Ein Ticket bei Google, wir haben
ein Ticket aufgemacht bei Red Hat
und Red Hat
hat noch nicht geantwortet oder Red Hat
möchte das haben. Ja, und dann sagt der das
seinem Chef und dann sind alle beruhigt. Also Supportverträge
im Enterprise Umfeld sind nicht so sehr
dafür da, um Probleme zu beheben,
sondern hauptsächlich zur Beruhigung
und eine Sache,
die man auch nicht unterschätzen darf, weil wir sind
ja im Business Enterprise Umfeld, es gibt
natürlich auch Zertifizierungen und ich meine damit
jetzt nicht irgendwie Red Hat Certified
Super Admin oder sowas, sondern
dass irgendein Hersteller sagt,
meine Software
ist nur zertifiziert für
Red Hat
8 oder so.
Und wenn ihr Support
wollt von mir, dann müsst ihr das
auf einer Supportplattform betreiben,
auch wenn es zu 99%
nichts mit der Plattform zu tun hat, wenn meine Software
scheiße ist, aber wenn ihr es auf einer
anderen Plattform betreibt, dann werde ich euch bei jedem
Supportticket sagen, dass ihr das
nicht auf einer supportten Plattform betreibt und
deswegen wir euch nicht helfen können.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, das ist eine riesig große
sich selbst erhaltendes Gelddruck
Ökosystem
aus
Enterprise Distributionen, Zertifikaten
und Softwareherstellern.
Aus meiner Sicht sollte man da einfach gar nicht mitmachen
und sagen, ich scheiße auf euch, wenn ihr jetzt nicht in der Lage seid, eure
eure Software gescheit anzubieten.
Aber gut, das kann man sich im Enterprise Umfeld nicht immer so richtig aussuchen.
Du kannst den Red Hat Support prinzipiell wegen allem anhauen, was auf Red Hat ist.
Du darfst halt nicht damit rechnen, dass das wirklich dann explizit für dich gefixt wird.
Wobei man das doch gar nicht sagen kann, dass der Red Hat Support ist gar nicht so useless, wie man denkt.
Also wir haben auch tatsächlich schon Sachen dadurch, dass wir uns beschwert haben, gefixt bekommen.
Wahrscheinlich waren wir bei weitem nicht die einzigen, die sich beschwert haben.
Ja, also also ich muss sagen, von den ganzen großen Supports, Dinger, die ich mitbekommen habe, sei es Microsoft, Oracle, Red Hat, Google, haben wir da sonst noch?
SAP.
Und sonst was?
Und sonst was muss ich sagen, ist der Red Hat Support wahrscheinlich noch der nützlichste.
Die Red Hat Knowledge Base ist auch nicht verkehrt, die man natürlich auch nur hinter einer Paywall hat.
Trotzdem ist die Red Hat Knowledge Base schlechter als das Archlinux Wiki.
Ne, das kann man so nicht sagen, das behandelt komplett unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe.
Also die Red Hat Knowledge Base ist gar nicht so schlecht, ja.
Wenn du irgendeinen komischen Fehler im Log hast und du suchst danach.
Und wenn du Glück hast, dass Red Hat ein Knowledge Base ist.
Wenn man einen Knowledge Base Artikel darüber hat, dann sind die Chancen auch relativ hoch, dass das irgendwas von Menschenhand erstellter Content ist, den du da findest, der sich auch explizit wirklich auf deine Red Hat Version und deine Probleme bezieht.
Also es ist nice to have.
Es ist nichts, wofür ich normalerweise so viel Geld rausgeben würde.
Also wenn ihr mich fragt, ich persönlich würde meinen Krempel nur unter Debian laufen lassen.
Im Serverbereich.
Debian.
beste aber im enterprise umfeld ist es halt red hat wegen alledem was ich erzählt habe
ihm leider ja debian beste oder debian wie es die coolen leute nennen aber ansonsten lego
bauvideos gucke ich mir immer gerne an waffen testen für die bundeswehr gehalt als ziviler
ingenieur das gucken wir uns jetzt an enemy ac 130 above dann machst du die stellanzeige
fertig das ist eine gute frage wir haben ja noch ganz viele stellanzeigen offen irgendwo weiß ich
noch nicht demnächst holst du dir die wissen nein mache ich nicht was soll ich damit sehe ich sehe
den den großen wobei kommen wir gucken uns wird das interessiert mich tatsächlich auch wir hatten
noch so ein video hier gerade offen mit der apple vision pro langzeit test das können wir
uns tatsächlich mal gucken ich habe bis also mal
eine meinung zur vision pro war ja das ist so ein ding was apple jetzt nicht für den end user
rausgebracht hat zum aktuellen zeitpunkt sondern quasi als produkt wo jetzt einfach ein paar jahre
reifen muss bis es dort gute end user anwendungs cases gibt ob das jetzt der fall ist wage ich zu
bezweifeln weil es ist wie immer mit vr oder a er muss man ja sagen es gibt immer mal wieder so ein
kleinen hype bei den hersteller was rausbringt es ist wie immer mit vr oder a er muss man ja sagen es gibt immer mal wieder so einen kleinen hype von irgendeiner hersteller was rausbringt es gibt immer mal wieder so einen kleinen hype von irgendeiner hersteller was rausbringt
aber am ende benutzt keiner ich glaube das beste beispiel dafür ist diese ganze metaverse geschichte
was da alle immer drum herum gelabert haben aber im endeffekt ist interessiert keine sau keine
ahnung keine erfahrung vom namen irgendwann mal gehört sagt mir nichts also mit dem aktuellen
stand gar nicht also wenn die nicht noch super neue tolle anwendungszwecke finden ich glaube
der main stream x der anwendungszweck für eine vr brille ist wahrscheinlich vor ort
dürfte dürfte der vr chat oder sowas ich glaube ich glaube ja ohne mist ich glaube der meist
verbreitetste einsatzzweck für eine vr brille dürfte tatsächlich das hier sei zurzeit geht
auf apple glaube ich nicht ja dann gekauft sich auch keiner gucken uns mal an was was was apple
so treibt ja und schreibe dieses video auf meinem 100
50 zoll notebook display und ich habe hier so vor mir auch noch irgendwelche schwebenden fenster
in die luft gehängt ja und eigentlich ließe sich das total gut aushalten hier aber ich habe ja
dummerweise über 600 gramm headset auf dem kopf und das tut mir ein bisschen weh auferstehen ihr
könnt es euch vielleicht schon denken das hier ist unser apple vision pro langzeiterfahrungs video
denn das teil kommt ja jetzt auch in deutschland in den handel jetzt darüber dem jahr habe ich
und inzwischen sehr viele erfahrungen damit gesammelt nicht nur ich sondern auch etliche
kolleginnen und kollegen von heise online ct meganeye und ich habe das headset auch dutzenden
von leuten bei irgendwelchen veranstaltungen auf den kopf gesetzt und da auch ziemlich viel gelernt
so und statt euch aber jetzt so ein zweistündiges video mit technischen details vorzusetzen das hat
ja sowieso auch schon norm von tested gemacht versuche ich jetzt in 20 minuten euch alles
wissenswerte über dieses wirklich sehr besondere gerät zu erzählen also meine sieben minuten
wichtigsten welches terminal ich benutze nicht nur weil es das hier das ist western wetz wetz term
beste aus meiner sicht das beste terminal was es gibt für linux unter mac kann man vielleicht
sagen item ist auch noch neues item 2 ist ja aber ich sonst insgesamt muss ich sagen beste
termin es gibt nichts besseres windows geht das übrigens auch apple super fans sondern das richtet
sich für technik interessieren und boiler ich halte die vision prof ein technisches meisterwerk
glaube aber trotzdem dass sie glauben wird okay ja so ungefähr denke ich mir das auch schon die
ganze zeit ja dieses video wird gesponsert von nord vpn wenn ihr euch ein netzteil stellt okay
neuen pc zusammen stellt dann solltet ihr nicht beim netzteil sparen das stelle ich da hat er recht
sehr viele probleme auch wenn er das nur sagt weil es die sonic sponsoren aber das stimmt ich weiß da
wovon ich spreche also lieber was hochwertiges wie die vertex serie von c-sonic die erfüllen
den aktuellen atx 3 standard die haben einen vollmodularen kabelsatz dadurch passen die auch
in kleinere gehäuse und die haben zwölf jahre garantie und zwar sogar mit austausch service
defekt gegen nagelneu und schick aussehen tun die auch noch die c-sonic vertex netzteile Werbung Ende
auszahlservice ist halt auch so ein Ding wenn dein pc abgeraucht ist da musst du erst mal den
Support raussuchen da hinschreiben und du brauchst bestimmt eine Woche bis das hast inzwischen sein
hast dir bei Amazon neues bestellt und hast einen Tag später das Netzteil da das werden die meisten
Leute wahrscheinlich eher bevorzugen was ist die Apple vision Pro überhaupt und was will die und
was kostet die die Apple vision die kostet zu viel ab dem 12. Juli 2024 in Deutschland
die Apple vision Pro kommt ab dem 12. Juli 2024 in Deutschland
die Apple vision Pro kommt ab dem 12. Juli 2024 in Deutschland in den h viktigt prozess
die Apple vision Pro kommt ab dem 12. Juli 2024 in Deutschland in den h wichtig prozess
die Apple vision Pro kommt ab dem 12. Juli 2024 in Deutschland in den h nichts kostet
happened open
garden
undonic
viele andere Sachen, für das sie sich halt einfach andere Wörter ausgedacht haben als der Rest der
Welt. Also, AVP ist ein Virtual Reality Headset oder auch Mixed Reality Headset, weil das hier
außen mehrere Kameras eingebaut hat. Ich dachte, die coolen Leute nennen das mittlerweile Augmented
Reality. Dass man im Headset nicht nur komplett computergenerierte Welten sehen kann, wie in
Virtual Reality, sondern auch die echte Umgebung und vor allem eine Mischung daraus, also Mixed
Reality. Bei Apple heißt das halt aber Spatial Computing, also räumliche EDV auf Deutsch. Und ja,
das kann man so nennen, aber nennt der Rest der Welt halt anders. Aber wenn wir sowieso gerade
über Mixed Reality sprechen, die Apple Vision Pro hat hier sogar so einen Drehknopf, mit dem ich den
Übergang zwischen echter und künstlicher Welt stufenlos einstellen kann. Das ist echt eine
lustige Idee, finde ich. Bei dem 550 Euro Headset Meta Quest 3 schalte ich echte Welt und VR mit
so einem Doppelklopfen aufs Gehäuse um. Das ist echt eine lustige Idee, finde ich. Bei dem 550 Euro
Headset Meta Quest 3 schalte ich echte Welt und VR mit so einem Doppelklopfen aufs Gehäuse um. Und
daran sieht man auch recht anschaulich, in ihrer Grundfunktion kann die 4000 Euro AVP nicht mehr
als deutlich, deutlich günstigere andere Headsets. Aber, und das muss ich auch so deutlich sagen,
hatte ich noch kein Headset auf dem Kopf, das ein so beeindruckendes Bild zeigt wie die AVP. Und
der Unterschied ist so groß, dass es Anwendungen gibt, die wirklich nur auf der AVP Sinn ergeben
und nicht zum Beispiel auf der Quest 3. Und das ist direkt meine erste große Erkenntnis. Erkenntnis,
Nummer 1, die Apple Vision Pro ist extrem gut als Video-Konsummaschine geeignet. Oder sogar besser
gesagt, ich kenne kein anderes Headset, auf dem ich mir überhaupt Videos angucken würde. Mit der AVP
kann ich mir einfach eine riesige Leinwand aufziehen und da halt Filme, Serien oder YouTube-Videos
draufschauen. Und dank Leuten, die das Ding auseinandergebaut haben, weiß man inzwischen
auch recht genau, was da für Displays überhaupt drin sind. Nämlich zwei Micro-OLED-Bildschirme
mit jeweils 3660 x 3200 Pixeln. Boah, ordentliche Auflösung. Ordentliche Auflösung.
Also, die Auflösung auf der Größe, das ist ordentlich. Und die machen halt grob 4K-Auflösung
für jedes Auge. Und das sieht in der Praxis aber so gut aus, dass das Gehirn halt wirklich glaubt,
ja okay, das ist hier eine Kinoleinwand hier vor mir. Und es sieht auch nicht schlechter aus als
auf einer Kinoleinwand. Vielleicht sogar ein bisschen besser, weil halt die Projektion,
die ja keine Projektion ist, aber gleichmäßiger ist. Und alle, die das auch ausprobiert haben,
sagen, es sieht fantastisch aus. Ja, und man kann sich diese Leinwand halt auch fast beliebig groß
und klein ziehen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man im Bett oder auf dem Sofa liegt, so dass eine Wand
komplett mit Bild ausgefüllt ist. Oder man dreht die echte Welt direkt ganz weg und setzt sich oder
legt sich in so einen virtuellen Kinosaal oder halt auf den Mond. Und das habe ich mal gemacht
in so einer total hektischen und unangenehmen enger Flughafen-Lounge. Einfach AVP aufgesetzt,
einfach Realität ausgeblendet und da dann schön Filme geguckt. Das war wirklich eine Wohltat.
Das war wirklich angenehm. Also generell ist Videoconsum die von allen Leuten, die ich kenne,
die sich länger mit der AVP beschäftigt haben, mit Abstand die meist verwendete Anwendung auf
dem Ding. Damit meine ich jetzt erstmal normalen, flachen Videocontent. Also halt so ganz normal
Netflix oder Amazon Prime. Und genau für die beiden gibt es zwar keine speziellen AVP-Apps,
aber das klappt auch ganz normal im Browser. Oder sonst gibt es halt kurzem auch so eine 6-Euro-App,
die heißt SuperCut und mit der kann man Netflix und Prime auch einigermaßen komfortabel gucken.
Dann auch in 4K. Apple TV und Disney Plus haben... Ich glaube, der Akku war gar nicht so schlecht,
wenn ich das noch aus dem ersten Eindruck Video richtig im Hinterkopf habe. Also man
kann damit keinen Tag rumlaufen oder so. Aber ich glaube, so schlecht war der gar nicht.
...Apps, mit denen man das komplette Streaming-Angebot... Irgendwie fünf Stunden oder so.
...gucken kann. Aber zusätzlich gibt es hier auch viele... Ja, nur zwei Stunden. Okay,
wenn... Vielleicht wisst ihr das noch besser. ...DF-Filme, die ja normalerweise da nicht im
Angebot sind. Das ist gerade... Das ist gerade... Das ist gerade... Das ist gerade... Das ist gerade...
Dich. Oder? Also pharmacy. Auf protective foam, oder über eine
Regeneratoren-Det apocalypse, auf hochwertige Filter und so. Ich fand das zwar noch wie
bei Disney bzw. Pixar sehr nice, weil es da ja so gut wie jeden Film der letzten 15 Jahre
in stereoskopischem 3D gibt. Und das macht auf der AVP natürlich besonders viel Spaß.
Also mit 3D meine ich jetzt ganz normal wie im Kino. Also dass man da so eine Leinwand hat.
Dann gehen dann Sachen statementschecksachageroeben... Beeinstimmte Arbeitssicherheitsverse.
in einen Kasten reinguckt, in dem irgendwas passiert, sondern es ist auf jeden Fall das
komplette Sichtfeld ausgefüllt. Man kann sie also auch umgucken, nur eben nicht nach hinten,
das wäre dann ja 360-Grad-Video, das gibt es auch, aber das ist wirklich dann so Spezialistenzeug.
Ja, und das ist dann auch die Erkenntnis Nummer zwei, immersives 180-Grad-Video hat
einen riesigen Sprung nach vorne gemacht. Also natürlich erstens, weil die AVP so gute
Displays hat, aber auch, weil sich in der Kameratechnik viel getan hat. Wenn ihr mal
die Möglichkeit habt, eine AVP auszuprobieren, dann guckt auf jeden Fall diesen Immersive-Trailer
von Apple an. Das ist wirklich absolut beeindruckend. Aber Stichwort Apple,
die haben halt auch Interesse an solchen Inhalten und lassen die selbst aufwendig.
Na klar, das ist so wie früher auf den ganzen Fernseher, vielleicht könnt ihr euch da noch
erinnern, als Leute noch in den Mediamarkt gegangen sind und sich einen Fernseher gekauft haben,
da liefen überall irgendwelche Aquarium-Filmchen. So schön beleuchtete Aquarium-Dinger mit bunten
Filmen. Das ist ja auch so. Das ist ja auch so. Das ist ja auch so. Das ist ja auch so. Das ist
so effizient drin, weil das auf den Displays gut aussah. Natürlich fördert man erstmal
den Content, der auf dem jeweiligen Display gut ausschaut.
Es ist teuer zu produzieren die Frage ist, wie viel Inhalte wird es das geben noch in Zukunft.
Zurzeit gibt es da auch noch nicht so richtig viel. youth akan ll öğren can
ich einsenden aufängen.
Es gibt einmal so einen Kurzfilm von so einem Parcourt-Team, was so durch Paris parkourt.
Gerade bei dem Video musste ich wirklich manchmal die Augen zu machen, obwohl ich eigentlich
nicht so viel Hörenangst habe.
Aber das war so intensiv.
dass ich gedacht habe, oh Gott, nein, Augen zu machen.
Aber wirklich toll und wirklich beeindruckend.
Die Sachen findet man alle in der Apple TV App
und da braucht man nicht mal ein Apple TV Plus Abo für.
Das funktioniert auch ohne.
Erstaunlicherweise haben auch Erwachsenen Inhalte in 180 Grad 3D
eine fast so gute Bildqualität wie dieser High End Apple Content.
Und natürlich gibt es aber solches Zeug nicht bei Apple TV.
Ja, das ist ja klar.
Im App Store.
Man kann aber einfach auf die einschlägigen Websites im Browser gehen
und dann bei den Videos auf das Headset-Symbol klicken.
Mit der aktuellen Software-Version Vision OS 2 Beta 2
geht das ohne, dass man da irgendwas konfigurieren müsste.
Das Stichwort ist nämlich WebXR.
Das ist ein Standard, mit dem immersive Inhalte
einfach im Browser auf einem Headset nutzbar sind.
Und wenn ich mir das inzwischen extrem große Angebot
in dieser Richtung so anschaue, gehe ich mal davon aus,
dass das ziemlich viele Leute nutzen.
Ist auch mein Eindruck der ganzen Sache,
dass das tatsächlich eines der größten,
wenn nicht der Hauptanbieter,
Anwendungszweck ist,
wo das schon angekommen ist im,
nennen wir es mal Mainstream.
Das ist aber auch nicht das erste Produkt.
Guckt euch Videokassetten an,
guckt euch DVDs an.
Das sind alles Sachen,
das hat sich zuerst durchgesetzt
im Bereich von XXX.
Erkenntnis Nummer 3.
Die Bedienung ist genial,
aber stößt auch schnell an ihre Grenzen.
Die AVP hat ja Eye-Tracking eingebaut,
das heißt, Infrarot-Kameras nach innen verfolgen die Pupillen
und checken, wo man gerade so hinguckt.
Und die nach außen gerichteten Kameras können dann sehen,
was die Hände machen und werten zum Beispiel diese Geste hier
als Klick aus.
Man kann also zum Beispiel im Browser auf irgendeinen Link gucken.
Gibt es bestimmt auch, aber Plural war das schon nicht mehr so.
Da war die Zeit der Datenträger schon vorbei.
Und so machen und zack, ist man dann,
hat man den Link angeklickt.
Das geht extrem gut.
Man muss die Finger dafür nicht mal so vors Headset halten,
dass die auf jeden Fall gesehen werden,
dass man nicht auch so entspannt vorm Bauch oder so.
Was ich ganz erstaunlich fand,
dass wirklich alle Leute, die das Headset ausprobiert haben,
das sofort kapiert haben.
Also die konnten es sofort bedienen.
Egal, ob das jetzt so Tech-Freaks oder überhaupt keine Tech-Freaks waren,
egal, ob die jung oder alt waren,
das hat immer geklappt, bis es halt dann nicht mehr klappt.
Und das ist halt das Ding,
dass das Bedienkonzept wirklich darauf ausgelegt ist,
dass die Blickrichtung immer total exakt erkannt wird.
Und manchmal trackt das Headset leider nicht genau, wo man hinguckt.
Das kann einen komplett wahnsinnig machen.
Beispielsweise, wenn man auf einer Website irgendwo hinklicken will,
aber man trifft das nicht.
Egal, wie doll man das versucht, dann versucht man so ganz...
Ich glaube, da haben heute die wenigsten Leute Probleme dabei.
Ich meine, du hast heute ein Handy,
permanent mit einer Kamera am Start, überall, also doll.
Irgendwann hab ich schon mal versucht, ganz doll irgendwo hinzugucken.
Ja, es ist anstrengend auf jeden Fall.
Also funktioniert manchmal nicht.
Glücklicherweise passiert das nicht so oft, aber schon so regelmäßig,
dass ich das als Problem mit mir mache.
Wenn ich das als Problem mitzeichnen würde.
Eine weitere Sache sind zusätzliche Bedienkonzepte,
die nicht so intuitiv sind.
Also zum Beispiel, dass man ein Fenster zumacht,
den man da so nach unten auf den Fensterrahmen guckt und dann links...
Ja, das ist halt so ein Apple-Ding, da musst du dich dran gewöhnen.
...und dann macht man da dann die Klickgeste.
Oder seit Neuestem, also seit der Vision OS 2 Beta,
gibt es auch Gesten für Lautstärkeregelung
und um in das Kontrollzentrum zu kommen
und auch um das Hauptmenü aufzurufen.
Ja, vorher musste man halt entweder den Knopf dafür drücken
fürs Hauptmenü
oder das Kontrollzentrum so ganz unnatürlich nach oben gucken,
was ich ziemlich nervig fand.
Und jetzt kann man die eigene Hand angucken,
Daumen und Zeigefinger zusammen machen und dann die Hand umdrehen.
Und lässt man dann Daumen und Zeigefinger noch mal lange zusammen,
dann kann man so die Lautstärke einstellen.
Drückt man das kurz zusammen,
dann öffnet sich das Kontrollzentrum, also mit umgedrehter Hand.
Und ihr merkt jetzt schon, wie ich das so erkläre,
das ist dann nicht mehr intuitiv, sondern das muss man halt lernen.
Und wenn ich ehrlich bin, ist das dann auch der Punkt,
wo ich mir manchmal einen Controller gewünscht hätte,
weil das einfach zuverlässig ist.
Und das ist dann auch der Punkt,
wo ich mir dann auch so ein bisschen überlege,
wie das jetzt so ein bisschen zuverlässiger funktioniert.
Das wäre dann die Überleitung zur nächsten Erkenntnis.
Das ist nämlich Erkenntnis Nummer vier.
Es gibt ziemlich wenig Spiele.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Die AVP ist jetzt fast ein halbes Jahr auf dem Markt
und ich bin eigentlich davon aus.
Das ist halt auch das Ding.
Das ist auch ein Problem, was ich mir die ganze Zeit schon denke.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen draußen.
Und ich glaube auch, dass das der Versuch von Apple war,
jetzt das erst mal an Entwickler hauptsächlich zu bringen alles,
dass es einfach Content braucht dafür,
dass es auch nur eine Chance hat,
bei den normalen Leuten einzuschlagen.
Ausgegangen, dass in diesem Zeitraum hunderte VR-Spiele herauskommen würden,
weil man ja relativ einfache Umsetzungen
von vorhandenen SteamVR- oder Meta-Quest-Spielen machen kann.
Aber es ist nicht so.
Es gibt vielleicht so ein...
Das weiß ich ja.
Das kostet jetzt 4K.
Aber jetzt soll das ja sicherlich auch noch nicht,
oder zumindest ist das, was ich mir denke,
nicht den nur noch 15 normalen User ansprechen.
Jetzt soll das irgendwelche Entwickler ansprechen,
die was entwickeln.
Kommt dann vielleicht einmal in drei Jahren
die nächste Apple Vision dann...
Irgendwie anderes Wort hinten dran.
Die kostet dann nur noch die Hälfte.
Oder vielleicht nur noch ein Drittel.
Kann vielleicht nicht alles so.
Aber dann kommen wir in eine Region,
wo sich vielleicht normale Leute das kaufen.
Und dann gibt es halt schon Content.
Zumindest dachte ich, dass das der Plan von Apple war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der so aufgeht.
Grobes Dutzend AVP-Spiele in Apple Arcade,
also diesem Abo-Dienst.
Das sind aber wirklich relativ lahme Umsätze.
Das ist die Umsetzung von Casual Games Free Fruit Ninja.
Und Apple scheint es gerade bei Apple Arcade
total wichtig zu sein,
dass die Spiele die echte Umgebung auch anzeigen.
Also nicht komplett eine virtuelle Welt aufbauen.
Also, dass bei Fruit Ninja die Früchte halt
in meiner echten Umgebung rumschwirren
und nicht irgendwo anders.
Aber man kann ja auch komplett virtuelle Welten aufbauen.
Und solche Spiele gibt es auch.
Das sind aber wirklich sehr wenige.
Ein Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel der Job Simulator
und Vacation Simulator.
Das sind ja Klassiker.
So ein Schrott.
Für irgendwelche so langweiligen Simulator-Games
brauche ich jetzt natürlich ein 4K VR-Headset.
... von Pulse.
Das ist so ein Breakout-Klon.
Und das Ding hatte ich schon vor über zehn Jahren
für die Oculus Rift getestet.
Und hier bedient man den Schläger mit Kopfbewegungen,
weil damals gab es ja noch keine Handcontroller
bei den ersten Rifts.
Und die Vision Pro hat ja auch keine,
sondern die macht halt Handtracking.
Das ist zwar sehr präzise,
auch präziser als das Augentracking,
aber man kann damit grob gesagt nur zwei Zustände erfassen.
Also Hand auf, Hand zu.
Nicht geklickt, geklickt.
Gegriffen, nicht gegriffen.
Und das ist für die meisten Spiele viel zu wenig.
Die sind für unterschiedliche Buttons konzipiert.
Auf Controllern.
Ja, und ich denke, dass das damit zu tun hat,
warum es so wenig VR-Spiel-Umsetzungen gibt.
Eventuell hat es auch mit Apple zu tun,
die da blockieren im App Store.
Ich glaube aber auch,
dass es vor allem mit dem Controller-Problem zu tun hat.
Ja, und ich könnte mir halt auch letztendlich vorstellen,
warum entwickelst du da dafür großartig was,
wenn es so gut wie niemand gibt, das spielen kann?
Erkenntnis Nummer fünf.
Es ist immer noch unklar, was, also außer Video gucken,
jetzt die zwingende Killer-App für die AVP ist.
Also nicht falsch verstehen, man kann mit der AVP super arbeiten.
Also zumindest, wenn man einen Mac hat.
Also sich zum Beispiel den Screen des MacBooks in die Umgebung holen
und sich dann noch andere Screens oder 3D-Objekte ins Sichtfeld klatschen
und sich über die tollen Umgebungen freuen,
die man auch mit dem Rad rein- und rausdrehen kann.
Und ich finde auch diese super dezenten Animationen
in den Umgebungen wirklich gut gemacht.
Also dass sich hier die Wolken so ganz bisschen bewegen
und hier so das Wasser sich so ein bisschen bewegt.
Toll finde ich auf jeden Fall auch,
wie immer die Hände so realistisch da ausgeschnitten werden.
Und auch das ganz neue Feature,
wenn die AVP ein Apple-Notebook oder eine Apple-Tastatur erkennt,
wird die auch so dezent freigestellt.
Dann, wenn man also nicht zehn Finger tippen kann,
dann kann man auf der Tastatur gucken, wo das App-Zeichen ist oder so.
Das ist ein nettes kleines Detail.
Und insgesamt ist das natürlich alles cool.
Und wie gesagt, man kann damit arbeiten.
Aber das sind halt über 600 Gramm, die man im Gesicht hat.
Und das kann man vielleicht so halb auf dem Sofa lümmeln
für anderthalb Stunden ganz gut aushalten.
Und viel länger hält der Akku auch sowieso nicht.
Das sind so zwei Stunden.
Aber so ein ganzer Arbeitstag, das ist einfach zu heftig.
Da muss man schon wirklich schmerzfrei sein.
Guck mal, so sah mein Gesicht schon nach circa einer Stunde aus.
Okay, da habe ich auch das einfache Solo-Band verwendet,
das Dual-Knit-Band, das sogenannte.
Das hat oben hier auch noch mal so ein Band,
das verteilt das Gewicht also ein bisschen besser.
Also es geht nicht alles aufs Gesicht.
Aber auch mit dem Dual-Band kenne ich niemanden,
der oder die daran regelmäßig länger arbeitet.
Und ich kenne wirklich ziemliche VRMR-Nerds.
Und das liegt auch nicht nur an den Schmerzen auf dem Gesicht,
sondern halt auch, dass man für so einen Arbeitstag
zwingend an der Steckdose hängen muss,
was ich persönlich ganz schrecklich finde,
weil man ist da ja quasi angelegt.
Ja, das Problem mit Gegengewicht hintendran,
kann ich mir vorstellen,
ist, das ist bestimmt nice,
wenn du den Kopf in einer Position hast,
aber wenn du deinen Kopf drehst
oder wenn du öfters den Kopf bewegst, dann nicht.
... am Kopf und kann sich nicht mehr frei bewegen.
Also finde ich schwierig.
Erkenntnis Nummer 6.
Kurzsichtige Menschen brauchen wirklich Kontaktlinsen
oder die offiziellen Korrektur-Inserts für 169 Euro.
Ja, bislang konnte man VRMR-Headsets
ja mit den meist normalen Brillen darunter einigermaßen verwenden.
Die Apple Vision Pro ist aber jetzt so nah ans Gesicht gebaut,
dass das unter keinen Umständen geht.
Das bedeutet, wenn man kurzsichtig ist,
muss man entweder Kontaktlinsen reinmachen,
so mache ich das, pro Tipp,
Tageslinsen gibt es auch im Drogeriemarkt für günstig,
oder man kauft die offiziellen Zeiss-Linsen
für ziemlich happige 169 Euro.
Ich hatte bislang für alle meinen Headsets
immer die deutlich günstigeren Inserts
des deutschen Herstellers VR-Optica für 69 Euro benutzt.
Die haben immer supergut funktioniert.
Und das sind übrigens sogar auch Zeiss-Gläser.
Aber bei der AVP
funktionierten in unserem Test leider keinerlei Linsen von Drittherstellern.
Dafür müsste es wahrscheinlich einen Weg geben,
der AVP irgendwie mitzuteilen,
dass hier gerade andere Linsen drin sind.
Und das unterstützt Apple bislang nur bei den Originallinsen.
Da kriegt man nämlich so einen Code, den man abscannt,
und dann weiß das Headset,
aha, hier sind die und die Linsen drin, ich schalte mich so und so um.
Ja, und all das ist natürlich für Teams ein Problem,
bei denen sich vielleicht mehrere Leute gemeinsam eine AVP anschaffen wollen.
Also man braucht dann nicht nur
jeweils andere Gesichtspolster für unterschiedliche Personen,
weil da misst Apple vorab das Gesicht aus
und es gibt Dutzende unterschiedliche Gesichtspolster,
damit die perfekt passen,
sondern auch individuelle Linsen-Inserts natürlich,
also je nach Kurzsichtigkeit.
Also das solltet ihr unbedingt beachten,
wenn ihr euch so ein Ding kaufen wollt und das teilen wollt.
So, und Erkenntnis Nummer 7, die letzte,
das Außendisplay, das braucht niemand.
Und das funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
Die Apple Vision Pro berechnet ja eine sogenannte Persona,
also ein 3D-Modell,
von der Person, die das Teil auf dem Kopf hat
und setzt dann Mimik und Echtzeit auf dieses 3D-Modell um.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Also da sind Kameras nach innen gerichtet.
Das heißt, ich kann mit der AVP auf dem Kopf
an einem Teams- oder Zoom- oder Facetime-Meeting teilnehmen
und bin dann da, als einigermaßen lebensfähig,
Na, ich weiß ja nicht.
das Avatar zu sehen.
Und wenn ich Mund und Augen verziehe, so unterm Headset,
dann macht das der Avatar auch.
Das ist cool, das ist praktisch,
weil, also ich will ja nicht mich mit der Kamera aufnehmen,
wie ich so ein Headset auf dem Kopf hatte,
das ist ja viel besser so.
Und das funktioniert auch seit der ersten Software-Version,
die ich getestet habe,
ist aber jetzt mit den neuen Versionen
noch mal wirklich besser geworden.
Allerdings gibt es ja auch das sogenannte Eyesight.
Das ist so ein Außendisplay auf dem Headset,
wo die Augen des Avatars angezeigt werden,
auch in Echtzeit, auch wenn man die Augen auf und zu macht.
Ja, das ist ja offenbar dafür,
damit Außenstehende sehen,
dass sie mit Menschen kommunizieren können
und nicht so, dass der Mensch darunter nicht so abgeschottet wirkt
unterm Headset.
Das Problem ist nur, das Display ist so dunkel,
dass man das oft überhaupt nicht erkennen kann,
ob da überhaupt Augen drauf sind oder nicht.
Und die sehen auch nicht lebensecht aus,
sondern die sehen eher ein bisschen gruselig aus.
Es macht mich also nicht menschlicher, finde ich,
sondern eher am Gegenteil.
Mein Fazit.
Ich halte die Apple Vision Pro nach wie vor
für ein technisches Meisterwerk.
Also vor allem die Bildqualität ist wirklich immens gut.
Aber in der aktuellen Form
kann ich mir unter keinen Umständen vorstellen,
dass das ein Erfolg wird.
Vor allem, weil das Gerät
einfach 4.000 Euro kostet.
Und das in der Variante mit dem kleinsten Speicher.
Also wie gesagt, ich gehe davon aus,
dass wenn das vom Content her
halbwegs passen sollte in zwei, drei Jahren,
vielleicht noch irgendein günstigeres Modell kommt.
Weil dieses 4K-Modell, das wird sich keiner kaufen.
Dass das jetzt eher was ist,
was sich an Entwickler richtet.
Also mit 256 Gigabyte,
wenn Leute für ihr meistgenutztes Arbeitsgerät
4.000 Euro ausgeben,
dann empfinde ich das schon als viel.
Aber ja, dann kann man sich ja irgendwie sagen,
okay, damit verdiene ich mein Geld.
Da kann ich also ausnahmsweise so viel ausgeben.
Aber für so ein Ding,
dass man, wenn überhaupt,
nur ein paar Stunden pro Woche verwendet
und dann auch eher so als Freizeitgerät,
so als Fernsehersatz,
habe ich ja gerade schon gesagt,
dass die meisten Leute das machen.
Oh, schwierig.
Also es gibt da bestimmt ein paar Leute, die das kaufen.
Aber das sind nicht so viele, würde ich sagen.
Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass Apple das irgendwann noch mal
mit einer günstigeren Variante versucht.
Also zum Beispiel ohne dieses
sowieso unbrauchbare iSight-Display da draußen.
Und ja, wenn das dann auch nicht genügend Leute kaufen,
dann wird es das.
Voraussichtlich gewesen sein mit Apple Vision.
Und dann wird es das wirklich auch generell
mit VR, MR gewesen sein.
Also als Mainstream-Thema.
Also Sony hat ja auch schon unterschwellig die PSVR 2.
Es haben viele.
Es haben viele ausprobiert.
Und nirgendwo ist das so richtig.
Ich glaube, ich glaube,
das Mainstreamingste, was du zurzeit machen kannst,
also neben Porns gucken, ist VR Chat.
Niemals wirklich viel.
Und da kann man sich auch fragen,
sag mal so, die Schwelle,
die ist fließend zwischen Porn gucken und VR Chat.
Auch so VR-Hardware-Projekte von anderen Herstellern.
Das waren immer nur so Kurzzeitsachen.
Und wenn das jetzt nicht mal Apple hinbekommt,
die Leute davon zu überzeugen,
sich Displays aufs Gesicht zu schnallen.
Ja, da sehe ich irgendwie ein bisschen schwarz.
Also ich rede hier jetzt wirklich nur von VR, MR
als Mainstream-Produkte.
Ich gehe davon aus,
dass es in den nächsten Jahrzehnten
immer Headsets als Fan-Nischenprodukte geben wird.
Also für so Flug- und Fahrsimulationsleute
zum Beispiel für irgendwelche Visualisierungen.
Und vermutlich wird auch hin und wieder
mal ein interessantes Spiel dafür rauskommen.
Aber die Hoffnung vom Metaverse
als weltveränderndes Riesending,
also wie das Smartphone.
Also Spatial Computing als der Standardmodus,
mit dem wir irgendwie Technik bedienen,
also das kann man sich, glaube ich, alles abschmücken.
Also zumindest Stand jetzt.
Ja, aber wer weiß,
vielleicht bin ich auch viel zu pessimistisch.
Vielleicht kriegt das ja auch noch irgendjemand hin.
Vielleicht kriegt das Apple sogar hin.
Aber wenn dann nicht mit der aktuellen Generation
der Apple Vision Pro,
sondern mit einem Nachfolgeprodukt.
Oder wie seht ihr das?
Habt ihr die Apple Vision Pro schon vorbestellt?
Oder wollt ihr zumindest mal ein Demo gucken im Apple Store?
Das kann ich euch übrigens echt empfehlen.
Kann man online machen, ist auch kostenlos.
Und dann könnt ihr mal ein Gefühl dafür kriegen.
Oder sagt ihr auch, interessiert mich alles die Bohne,
lasst mich in Ruhe mit dem Headset-Kram.
Und gerne in die Kommentare schreiben,
lesen wir alles und abonnieren natürlich.
Ach so, ich sollte irgendwas machen.
Irgendjemand fragte, ob ich wirklich alle Kommentare lese.
Und dann sollte ich irgendeine Kopfbewegung machen,
fällt mir gerade ein.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall wirklich alle Kommentare gelesen.
Und das mache ich bei jedem Video.
Also, tschüss.
Ich mache das auch, wenn ich Videos mache.
Nun, I can't wait.
Leute, ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten, was es heute gibt.
Kommt ihr nie drauf.
Schnitzel Spaghetti.
Nudeln mit Lachs, korrekt.
Was soll es?
Es ist so.
Sonntag.
Vielleicht hören wir uns später noch.
Ich gehe jetzt erst mal was futtern.
Und fressen, Alter.
Bis später.
Macht's gut.